and now book TV is live with author and
historian Gerald Horne he's the author
of several books on race and history
including his most recent Paul Robeson
the artist as revolutionary for the next
three hours Gerald Horne will be
answering your questions
professor Gerald Horne in your book the
counter-revolution of 1776 you write as
the 21st century proceeds one point is
evident the heroic creation myth of the
founding of the u.s. is desperately in
need of revisiting what does that mean
what it means is that I think the
historians by and large have not done a
very good job of talking about the
founding of the United States of America
what's striking is that in history
departments from the Atlantic to the
Pacific
you have specialists who critiqued the
French Revolution the Russian Revolution
the Chinese Revolution the Cuban
Revolution but those who critique 1776
or few and far between despite the fact
that after the found the United States
of America you had more land
expropriated from Native Americans
clearly which meant that 1776 is not
necessarily a step forward for the
indigenous population and then by the
1790s you had the United States as a
note in that book had taken over the
control of the slave trade and Africans
to Cuba by the 1840s as I said in my
book the deepest south the us-brazil an
African slave trade United States had
taken control u.s. national had taken
control of the slave trade to Brazil so
it seems to me that minimally one can
say that 1776 was not a great leap
forward for Africans nor is it a great
leap forward for the indigenous
population it was a great leap forward
for many Europeans that is to be sure
but your pants are squeak well no do not
comprise the entirety of humanity and I
think what it said in motion is what
actually we're seeing in 2016 that is to
say with 1776 you had the progressive
expropriation of land from the
indigenous population and then that land
was parceled out oftentimes to Europeans
fresh-off-the-boat which helps to
solidify a cross class coalition between
poor Europeans and more fluent Europeans
at the expense of the indigenous
population and of course the Africans
who then stock that land
enslave bonded laborers and in 2016 once
again you see a kind of cross class
coalition on the Republican side
between an among Europeans of various
class backgrounds and for those who say
or who think that make America great
again
fundamentally makes means make America
white again well they have a point to be
made I think part of the problem is is
that since we haven't had a critique of
1776 to the extent that it deserves one
it becomes very difficult to understand
the present I mean if you go to a doctor
and you have an illness one of the first
things the doctor will do is take a
medical history hopefully you will
provide an adequate and accurate medical
history that will allow the doctor to
make a diagnosis and a prognostication
with regard to your future well-being
well we haven't had an adequate history
it seems to me of the founding which
makes it very difficult to understand
the present and in your book Powell V
Alabama you write the US had been
founded in the 18th century on the
principle of white supremacy well it
goes back to what I said a moment or two
ago that is to say that in some ways if
you look at 1776 and this is what I tell
my students when I teach these
undergraduates and introduction to
african-american studies that it's fair
to say that 1776 and the US Constitution
did represent a step forward in terms of
religious liberty to that point of
course religious wars had been racking
Europe in particular Protestant London
versus the so called Catholic powers
France and Spain
particularly the contestation over the
Americas portuguese of course also being
predominantly Catholic but what happens
with 1776 not argued that in order to
widen the base of support for the
Republican project in North America the
so-called Democratic project in North
America there was a step forward and
terms of religious liberty because
this allowed the settlers here to widen
their base of support against the crown
in London and so therefore it's fair to
say that these settlers and what the
America led by George Washington would
not have prevailed but for assistance
from Catholic friends this leads
inevitably and inexorably to the First
Amendment guaranteeing religious liberty
now even with that of course we all know
that anti-catholicism prevailed in the
19th century the burning of convents we
know that anti-catholicism prevailed a
century ago with the rise of the second
iteration of the Ku Klux Klan we also
know that despite step forward steps
forward in terms of the fight against
anti-semitism ninety Jewish forever even
2016 that particular beast continues to
raise this ugly head but generally
speaking 1776 was a step forward for
religious liberty but the historians
have missed this the flip side of that
coin that the so-called Republican
project did a meaning that religion took
a step backwards it also meant that
monarchy took a step backwards but
substituted the aristocracy of ancestry
and heritage and lineage as was
prevalent in London you have to add
aristocracy of race quite frankly which
of the country is still wrestling with
and in fact you can make the argument
and I have made the argument that that
project of the aristocracy of race
didn't begin to retreat until the 20th
century with the rise of the class
project
the rise of thriving trade unions the
rise of socialist countries national
liberation movements etc which men begin
to give assistance of those who are
suffering under the lash of racism and
white supremacy which forced an agonized
retreat from the most egregious aspects
of white supremacy in 1954 may 17 with
the Brown versus Board of Education
decision and then 1964 with the civil
rights act 1965 with the Voting Rights
Act but as that international assistance
and pressure began to wither in the
latter part of the 20th century in the
first decade or so of the 21st century
you begin to see a reassertion of some
of these uglier aspects of white
supremacy is represented for example
with this incredible spate of police
shootings in San Diego and Tulsa
Charlotte Chicago Milwaukee the list of
tortured sites is too numerous to
mention and part of the dilemma was a
black community in particular is that as
a result of Brown versus Board of
Education and that retreat from the more
egregious aspects of white supremacy a
trade-off was made that is to say the
more international was leaders of the
black community who were willing to make
these sorts of global alliances and
thinking of Paul Robeson in the first
place were marginalized isolated
demonized etc and so now as I've said
repeatedly and remember there's a
microphone in my face in 2016 despite
the fact that you have these major
crises Ukraine North Korea Syria submits
and a few there are a few black
intellectuals and leaders that have
anything credible or meaningful to say
despite the fact that any of those
crises inevitably or perhaps inevitably
could lead to something worse up to an
including planetary extinction perhaps
so this is where we stand in 2016 dr.
Horne 2.5 million people resided in the
US and 1776 what what was a role of
African Americans of slaves during the
revolution if any well we told in our
classrooms by Crispus Attucks who some
would have it that he was the first
person to lay down his life or Liberty
quote unquote
although of course Crispus Attucks is
defined as black in another country he
might have been defined as Native
American given his ancestry but what
we're not told of course generally
speaking is about the African
who fought against the founding of the
United State interestingly I was just
watching the second part of the second
version of roots called the first
version came out based on the Alex Haley
book in the 1970s it took the nation by
storm
I was watching this the second version
which just came out this year I believe
and they do a credible effort in terms
of trying to illustrate that last point
that I just made that is to say that
since Britain was on a faster track the
abolition of slavery as represented by
Somerset's case in June 1772 the black
population had reason to believe that
their interest would be better served if
the settlers were defeated that's a very
difficult point for people in United
States to grapple with I might also say
that there is another TV miniseries you
can find easily I won't mention the
sources the book of Negroes it's a de t
Black Entertainment Television EE the
supporters in Washington a BT Canadian
and South African production ethnic does
the best job yet in terms of film and
cinema in terms of preventing presenting
an accurate portrayal of the black role
during the 1776 war in any case enslaved
Africans of course were bonded laborers
as I tell the story if you're trying to
understand 1776 you should try to
understand 1688 that's the so-called
Glorious Revolution in England where the
wings of the monarch are clipped by the
rising merchant class to that point the
Royal African company which had been
under the thumb of the monarch was the
major force in terms of the African
slave trade but with the clipping of the
wings of the monarch there was a
deregulation if you like of the African
slave trade and merchants too numerous
to mention were able to enter this
odious commerce sailing to Africa manic
lling and handcuffing every African
sight with the maniacal energy of crazed
bees dragging them across the
to work in the tobacco fields of the
Chesapeake in particular and of course
in the Caribbean which up to the middle
of the 18th century London thought was
more valuable than the North American
mainland of course the story should be
told in terms of 1776 in conjunction
with the Caribbean because the Africans
outnumber the European sometimes at a
rate of 10 to 1 or 20 to winning the
Caribbean Jamaica antigua barbados
creating fertile ground for the rise of
slave revolts which is not only
jeopardizing the investments but
jeopardizing the lives of the slave
owners and their families and this of
course leads to a certain kind of
retrenchment on the mainland where the
ratios are much more favorable to
slavery but that does not necessarily
save the settlers because of 1739 you
have stoners revolt actually before that
in 1712
you have the revolt of the enslaved in
Manhattan 17:39 in South Carolina
basically spearheaded by Angolans who
not only many of them could speak
Portuguese but many of them were
actually Roman Catholic purportedly they
were trying to get to Spanish Florida
Florida at that time was controlled by
Spain and there was a direct
collaboration between Spain and the
enslaved Africans in South Carolina to
overthrow the settler class and South
Carolina and so what happens finally in
1756 to 1763 is the so-called Seven
Years War where London seeks to
eliminate the Spanish threat to their
settlements in Florida and the French
threat in Quebec because there's
evidence to suggest that the French were
assisting the Africans in Manhattan in
1712 that is a very successful effort
the Seven Years War of course we all
know that even today as we speak
Canada Quebec in particular has a
predominantly french-speaking population
but in any event London prevails they
want to tax the settlers because the
wars were to their benefit and this is
where the traditional narrative kicks in
because I think there is accuracy there
the settlers did not want to take the
taxes which is a very familiar theme and
Washington DC to this very day and that
leads to revolt against British rule in
collaboration with the French in
particular against London which then
brings us back to the Constitution and
the religious liberty the First
Amendment etc what was role of who was
Lord Dunmore and what was his role in
the revolution Lord Dunmore I was at a
conference the CUNY Graduate Center in
New York about a year ago and a leading
historian and he started off making what
he thought was a cynical comment about
the parallels between London Lord
Dunmore the last British colonial
governor in Virginia in 1775 and Abraham
Lincoln he thought it was a cynical
coming I thought he was about to say
something that I agree with it is to say
Lord Dunmore was very upset shall we say
with the fact that settlers led by
George Washington and Thomas Jefferson
wanted to overthrow a British rule in
Virginia and North America generally so
he tried to cut a deal with the Africans
as a matter of fact this is represented
and the second version of roots that I
was just making reference to to the
filmmakers credit and in return for
Liberty were they enslaved they would
fight with the Redcoats with London's
forces of course this is not when Lord
Dunmore many plaudits amongst the
settlers to put it mildly he became a
notoriously unpopular but this meaning a
story in what he was going what he
thought was a parallel between Lord
Dunmore and Abraham Lincoln I think he
was making a point unintentionally which
is of course that the Emancipation
Proclamation January 1st 1863 and some
measure as I say in my book negro
comrades of the crown was a military
measure because in terms of trying to
free the enslaved population that the
United States did not have jurisdiction
over that is the same the so-called
Confederate States of America that was a
turning point in terms of the war
because it allowed for the enlistment
more black soldiers is represented in
the film glory starring Denzel
Washington and this then allows the u.s.
or the Union forces to blue to prevail
over the grade code so-called
Confederate States of America it didn't
work in 1775 but Lord Dunmore for
various reasons including the fact that
there is no criticism of Lord Dunmore
that he didn't go far enough that he
should have been trying to offer a
freedom to the enslaved a loyalist let
us say those who did not defect from the
Union Jack from from London but in any
case the Lord Dunmore is a very
important figure in the foundation of
United States of America Gerald Horne if
you were to write a general history book
for school kids today what would be the
first line in that book I'm not sure
what the first line would be but I'm
giving a talk in a few days at the
Association for the study of
african-american life and history
founded by according to you witsand
leading black historian over a century
ago and in that talk taking off from an
important seminar that was held in
Washington DC in May 2016 and the run up
when it was first initiated to the
opening of the National African American
Museum here in Washington which has
received reams of publicity for
understandable reasons and at that
seminar in Washington in May one leading
historian as accent a number of
historians asked we need a new
interpretive framework for the United
States of America one historian said is
from slavery to freedom popular
popularized by John Hope Franklin is
that still a valid interpretive
framework for black American history or
August Meyer and Eliot rut wit from
plantation to ghetto another story and
said we're actually what we need is a
new interpretive framework for u.s.
history and what I'm going to say in
Richmond in a few days is answer to that
latter question is yes and it should be
from settler colonialism
u.s. imperialism and as I tell this
audience in Richmond that will allow us
to incorporate more effectively the
present-day diversity of the black
American population in Houston for
example where I teach the black American
population has been enriched from
endlessly by waves of migrants and
immigrants from Nigeria in particular
people think of Hakeem Olajuwon for
example the University of Houston
basketball store was on to perform for
the Houston Rockets and the Toronto
Raptors in New York City for example for
at least a century if not longer there
has been a tidal wave of migrants from
Jamaica Antigua Barbados in Miami a
significant number percentage of black
population has roots in Haiti in
particular and for various reasons the
traditional narratives are not able to
account for that kind of diversity and
that's why I think we need this new
interpretive framework so that we can
account for the actual reality on the
ground
you mentioned earlier Paul Robeson from
your new book Paul Robeson the artist is
revolutionary you right you cannot fully
appreciate how the Jim Crow system came
to an end without an understanding of
the life of Paul Robeson Robeson
pioneered the struggle against Jim Crow
throughout the 30s and 40s that is true
despite the fact that I wrote it that is
to say that Paul Robeson a black
American born in New Jersey in 1898
passing away in Philadelphia in 1976
leading scholar as an undergraduate of
Rutgers University and Brunswick New
Jersey where he stars on the gridiron
stars as a baseball catcher stores and
athletics generally leaves there and
goes to Columbia University and
graduates was on the fast track to
becoming a lawyer but is diverted
although I should say that he also is an
early
former and professional football but his
careers of lawyers diverted and he
stumbles into performing and becomes a
leading actor a kind of precursor of
Denzel Washington or Will Smith if you
lot if you like not only on the screen
silver swinging but also on stage a
fellow is the signature role a good deal
of his stardom is created in London
where he lives from the early 1920s
until the late 1930s were intermittent
trips to the United States of America
there is a whole digression we could
engage in now with regard to a black
expatriates and how so many black
Americans over the decades and centuries
have been treated much better abroad
than in the place of their birth which
leads to this express writing themselves
to live overseas but a turning point for
Paul Robeson comes when he visits newly
fascist Germany in the early 1930s and
comes face to face with the rising tide
of fascism he also goes on to Moscow
where he encounters another black lawyer
William Patterson who I wrote a
biography about that came out a few
years ago who graduated from Law School
the University of California Hastings
now the Hastings School of Law in San
Francisco and of course attempted
undergraduate school to University
California at Berkeley where I attended
law school and William Paterson had
become an early member of the US
Communist Party had gone to Moscow to be
trained as a professional revolution or
actually spoke some Russian he convinces
Robeson that he should devote more of
his time and energy to the cause of his
people this was during the context of
the Scottsboro case the subject of the
book I wrote Powell versus Alabama and I
mentioned that of course shortly the
details of that case but in any case of
Paul Robeson is convinced that he should
spend
time in the United States of America
facilitating that is the onset of World
War two in Europe in 1939 he has reason
to believe that he and his family might
be trapped in London you know that
weapon was bombed repeatedly by the
German fascists during World War two
people were sleeping in subways at 7:00
so he returns the United States helps to
convince black Americans that they
should throw in their lot with the
United States and the anti-fascist cause
and that's not necessarily a slam-dunk
proposition because writing a book that
will be published Nick here but NYU
press called facing the Rising Sun
african-americans Japan and the rise of
afro-asian solidarity which talks about
the Tokyo sentiment in black America in
fact in this book I talk about how in
November 1942 in East st. Louis Illinois
right across the Mississippi River from
my hometown of st. Louis you have black
Americans in military uniforms rolling
in anticipation of a Japanese invasion
of North America that's the kind of
sentiment that Paul Robeson had to
overcome which he successfully does
convincing black Americans months again
that they should make the ultimate
sacrifice of blood sacrifice to help to
rescue the end states but no good deed
goes unpunished and so after World War
two with japan defeated as the result of
the atomic bombing of a russian nagasaki
august 1945 the Red Scare starts and
Paul Robeson who was a socialist thought
to be a communist is persecuted and
demonized his income falls from the six
figures to the four figures his passport
is taken so he cannot travel abroad to
make a living but he's still dishing out
blows despite the blows that he's
absorbing 1950 1951 Robeson in Patterson
file a petition with United Nations
storage the United States with genocide
against like people reference here an
article in The Washington Post just a
few days ago for a United
body said that because of the racial
terrorism inflicted among black
Americans that black Americans deserve
reparations for the maltreatment and
mistreatment they've absorbed over the
years this genocide petition recharged
inside it's translated into numerous
languages it's sold all over the world
but this does not necessarily when
plaudits in Washington a Paul Robeson is
Hall repeatedly before congressional
committees Patterson in fact is jailed
Paul Robeson is not jailed but his
income does plummet finally an
international movement leads to the
return of Paul Robeson's passport he
immediately D counts to London and stars
once again an Othello but by 1965 not
only is this health deteriorating but
his wife had passed away so he returns
the United States and becomes a virtual
recluse in a working-class community in
Philadelphia until he passes away in
gender in 1976 although the mention of
the book he is saluted by the rising
civil rights movement the Coretta Scott
King Martin Luther King even Andrew
Young forces and snikt the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee the
shock troops of the movement in the deep
south they're all very praiseworthy if
you like a Paul Robeson although he's
more controversial shall we say in other
circles but as I say in the last
paragraph of that book there are those
who would suggest that the figure of
Stalin the former leader in Moscow for
30 years
thus credits the idea of socialism for
all time and in fact the Robeson project
if that's the case why is in the African
slavery the square to the United States
for all time it's credit to capitalism
for all time why the double standard
until we unravel these nuts I think
you'll be wandering in the wilderness
you said thought to be a communist was
it illegal to be a communist in the u.s.
effectively after 1949
when another comrade of Paterson Robison
Ben Davis jr. a black man born in
Atlanta his father was a leading member
of the Republican Party and one of the
most affluent black Americans in the
United States and Ben Davis Union went
on to Amherst College and Harvard Law
School but join the Communist Party in
the early 1930s and it was electric in
New York City Council in 1941 I believe
1943 re-elected in 1945 before al stood
unceremoniously perhaps illegally in
1949 and then put on trial and then was
jailed that or prison and Terry help
Indiana in some ways that effectively
illegalized
the Communist Party and even if that's
not a technically accurate assertion
certainly I think it's fair to say that
the persecution and demonizing of those
who have advocated for socialism United
States has left a continuing shadow over
this country and that's why I'm very
appreciative of the campaign of senator
Bernie Sanders of Vermont who went a
long way towards helping to detoxify the
concept of socialism and clarifying the
concept of socialism and in the process
attracting many Millennials that is to
say us folk under the age of 35 to his
banner but in any case there's still an
uphill climb it seems to me with regard
to that process that Bernie Sanders did
so much to assist Gerald Horne how do
you identify yourself politically
identify myself my late friend Manning
Marable
called himself he was the biographer of
Malcolm X you might recall winning a
Pulitzer Prize he called himself and I
was part of his cohort radical Democrats
and I accept that term accept the term
socialist as well accept the term
anti-fascists I accept
earng Black Liberation militant I accept
the term peace activists accept the term
feminist accept the term humanitarian I
mean I think I have multiple identities
that I embrace what about communists
some of my best friends are communists
but as I said in my book on John Howard
Lawson the hollywood the jewish american
communist and founder of the
screenwriters still when they would ask
him if he were a communist he would say
we're not allowed to say that's a joke
but some of my best friends a communist
jarvis Tyner new york city who served a
long time as a leader of the u.s.
communist party the brother mccoy tyner
the great pianist so i identify what
that movement certainly your producers
asked me before this program people i
found inspiring and one of the people i
listed was Govan and becky gova and
becky was a leader of the South African
Communist Party a party that works hand
in glove with the African National
Congress of South Africa of Nelson
Mandela and as you accept what the late
anglo-dutch historian Stephen Ellis says
in one of his books Nelson Mandela
himself had been co-opted to the Central
Committee of the South African Communist
Party and there's a full history
interview at the University of
Connecticut in stores just read a few
days ago by Andrew Allegheny who was in
cell block 7 Mandela and so black 5 at
Robben Island this M serving or it might
have been a reverse who confirms what
Stephen Ellis is written Pablo Picasso
Sean O'Casey the great Irish writer Oh
so I don't I don't run in horror from
the idea of even being called a
communist throughout your 31 books there
seems to be this confluence of
Communists and african-americans and
their causes that's true although of
late you might have noticed I've been
writing more about slavery and what's
striking about that is that in some ways
is more difficult to write about slavery
and publish about slavery in the United
States than to write about communists as
I do which is very interesting I think
it's because slavery hasn't here and
it's a very difficult question still for
people to grapple with and and to
reconcile the the soaring narrative
uplifting narrative United States with
this gruesome dirty story of what
happened to Africans so it's easier to
try to glide past it but certainly I've
written a number of books about a
communist including in fact a book about
Hawaii fighting in paradise labor unions
I can't remember the subtitle labor
unions and communists was making a
modern Hawaii something like that where
I talk about the Frank Marshall Davis
and my writing about Frank Marshall
Davis has launched right wing blogs too
numerous to mention because like
Marshall Davis was very closely a shirt
associated shall we say with a Communist
Party of a lie which was probably the
most successful communist party under
the US flag he was a black American or
in Kansas came to prominence in Chicago
before moving to Honolulu on December
7th 1941 live in infamy and there he
comes to mentor a young man who grows up
to be present at States of course that's
where the right wing blog Center
because of course that simple fact has
led some to suggest that the president
of state insuring candidates of the
speed tutored by this communist to move
into the White House to wreak havoc on
the United States of America but as I
say in the book if you look a Honolulu
if you look at Hawaii where left
influence was the strongest under the US
flag you'll find a state that was in the
vanguard in terms of women's right to
choose under the US flag in terms of
labor union protection for example this
was doing no small measure to the
efforts of the International Longshore
and warehouse and human headquartered in
San Francisco under the leadership of
Harry bridges you may recall was accused
of being a communist the United States
tried to deport him numerous times well
born in Melbourne Australia he course
migrates to San Francisco in the 1930s
where it leads to San Francisco general
strike at 1934 and then begins to
unionize the islands the archipelago of
Honolulu and helps to convert what was
really a white supremacist redoubt into
what has become the most progressive
force under the US flag I mean that's
the kind of story that I try to write
about and talk about when I write about
communists and let me crowdsource at
this point I would really like to write
some more about Hawaii a very pleasant
place to visit and do research so any
callers listeners people tweet Facebook
email we got a project that will bring
me back to Hawaii please communicate it
to me sooner rather than later and good
afternoon and welcome to book TV on
c-span 2 this is our monthly in-depth
program where we invite one author on to
talk about his or her body of work and
this month it's professor Gerald Horne
he teaches at the University of Houston
and here's a partial list of his
currently 31 books fired this time the
Watts up
and the 1960s came out in 1997 Powell V
Alabama the Scottsboro Boys an American
justice also came out in 1997 race women
woman the lives of Shirley Graham Dubois
came out in 2000 class struggle in
Hollywood came out in 2001 race war
white supremacy and the Japanese attack
on the British Empire came out in 2003
black and brown African Americans in the
Mexican Revolution 2005 w eb de bois a
biography came out six years ago the
counter revolution of 1776 which we've
discussed briefly came out in 2014 race
to revolution the u.s. and Cuba during
slavery and Jim Crow also came out that
year and last year confronting black
jacobins the u.s. the Haitian Revolution
and the origins of the Dominican
Republic and finally his most recent
book is on Paul Robeson the artist as
revolutionary this is your chance to
talk with Professor corn we're going to
put the phone numbers up here in a
second we're also going to show you ways
that you can contact us via social media
2:02 is the area code seven four eight
eighty two hundred if you live in the
East and Central time zones seven four
eight eight two zero one for those of
you in the mountain and Pacific time
zones now you can also email professor
horn at book TV at c-span no RG or you
can send a tweet at book TV is our
Twitter handle and finally facebook.com
slash book TV is our Facebook page
you'll see it right there at the top of
the page you can make a comment under
his picture there
professor horn March 1931 mmm-hmm
what happened this is the Scottsboro
case a case that I write about and
DiPalma Alabama book in a case that I
also talk about in my biography of
William Paterson University of Illinois
press black revolutionary as I tell the
story it's the turning point in the
history of the struggle against Jim Crow
us a party these were nine black youth
arrested for allegedly sexually
molesting two euro-american women on the
fast track in Alabama to being executed
to fate and destiny of so many black
Americans before and since accused
falsely of crimes but what happens is
that William Paterson intervenes in the
form of assistance of an international
labor defense a so-called communist
front certainly it had been initiated
and energized by the u.s. Communist
Party assisted by Moscow and it helps to
organize an international campaign
around the case of the Scottsboro nine
as they were called but it's also marks
a turning point because what happens is
that international pressure is placed on
the United States to retreat from the
more egregious and horrible aspects of
Jim Crow there are demonstrations at US
embassies and consulates all over the
world in my book on Cuba talk about the
demonstrations that take place in Havana
were actually Cubans or killed
protesting in favor of the Scottsboro
nine this case leads to important
Supreme Court presidents with regard to
the right to trial by jury having black
Americans in fact serve on juries these
US Supreme Court presidents are still
being utilized to this very day
so the Scottsboro case is a necessary
prelude to talking about Brown versus
Board of Education and the Montgomery
bus boycott etc although I think that
the difference between these two
historical epics the 1930s in the 1950s
is that by the 1950s people like Paul
Robeson and William Paterson were on the
defensive and the movement which was
then benefiting from the fact the United
States was seeking to accuse Moscow of
human rights violations that found it
difficult to do so
as long as the stain of Jim Crow was
permanently cited on the escutcheon of
the United States of America this
creates a dynamic were by Jim Crow
retreats in the 1950s the problem being
that the leadership at that time was not
as internationally connected or
sophisticated as the Robeson's and
Pattersons and therefore were not able
to take advantage of the favorable
objective conditions that then obtained
but in any case the Scottsboro case is a
highly important case it's been written
about numerous times by a number of
historians has been the subject of
cinema at least TV movies as I recall
and certainly deserves all of the
attention that is received was it widely
publicized outside of northern Alabama
at the time absolutely it was a national
case and in fact it was a global case
there is a book Princeton University
Press published a few years ago about
some of the international aspects of the
Scottsboro case it was very embarrassing
to the United States of America because
of course when you talk about the
Scottsboro case you open the door to a
larger discussion of so-called
separate-but-equal of so-called the Jim
Crow us a party not only separate
schools but separate Bibles to be sworn
in on and on in the courtroom some of
the laws descend to the level of
absurdity making it illegal for black
and white workers so we got out the same
window there working in the same factory
for example this sort of international
scrutiny causes the more sober and
realistically minded us leaders to come
to the conclusion that Jim Crow should
be at least reduced it's not eroded the
problem there and this is where some of
not only our intellectuals but our
leaders have a deficit is that if you
look at sports for example also I'm
looking to write a book on base
anybody has any ideas they want to feed
me through social media or otherwise if
you look at baseball before the advent
of Jackie Robinson in 1946-47 black
American athlete with the Brooklyn
Dodgers or the explosion of Dominican
players coming on to the diamond in 2016
you could have a one-armed White House
fielder like Pete gray play for the st.
Louis Browns because of Jim Crow so when
you allow these exceedingly competent
and talented black Americans and Latinos
to come onto the diamond there's not
much of a market for a one-armed white
outfielder so even though one can make
the argument and this is what our
intellectuals and leaders do that when
Jackie Robinson and company entered
baseball it allow major-league baseball
to flourish it's true you see teams
start in San Francisco and Los Angeles
by 1957-58 television contracts more
wealth generated which then the players
can share it and that's all true so in a
sense Jim retreated from Jim Crow has
beneficial to many but there wasn't
necessarily official to people like Pete
gray and I think also complimenting if
you like what I just said
our intellectuals and leaders oftentimes
downplay the resistance to desegregation
as expressed in Little Rock in 1957
where President Eisenhower has to deploy
federal troops to ensure desegregation
Little Rock Central High School or
Oxford Mississippi where I was just
visiting just a few weeks ago University
of Mississippi once again federal troops
have to be deployed so the james
Meredith could desegregate University of
Mississippi the Bob Austin busing crisis
so showing that this was not just
limited to the retro grab precincts of
Dixie because the violence in the uproar
in Boston was quite significant as
anybody who's familiar with Bill Russell
the black American basketball star in
his memoirs talking about the racism
Boston readily access to that or in the
1980s and 1990s in Yonkers with the
housing desegregation crisis which was
just very usefully depicted and the
drama showed me a hero which I recommend
that that resistance oftentimes sense to
be downplayed and it's always sort of
assumed that people think it's a good
idea to move away from Jim Crow and move
away from desegregation which then makes
them surprise surprise when a Donald J
Trump Rises and is able to get garner
mass support there was a headline in
Gale column Gayle Collins column in the
New York Times just a day or two ago
where she expressed surprise than
anybody was voting for Donald J Trump
and you have a number of people who
express surprise but I just shows me
they don't not familiar with the history
of this country or the reality at this
country and even some of the friends on
the Left have not been very helpful in
this regard I mean Paul Krugman of the
New York Times to his credit and it's
Colin just a few days ago introduced the
concept of white national that comes
from a liberal not from one left of
liberal the conservative LA Times
columnist Jonah Goldberg has been
talking repeatedly about what he calls
white identity politics in terms of
explain the rise of Donald J Trump that
doesn't come from our friends left of
liberalism that comes from a
conservative one of the problems that we
face in this country is that those who
consider themselves the most
sophisticated in terms of their analysis
oftentimes really hard be I don't need
somebody pounding and think they read
the newspapers every day which should be
cast one for anybody who's serious about
politics in any case that's my spiel for
the Sunday after where did the term Jim
Crow confirm professor it comes from
minstrel see minstrel see was a very
popular
performance art in the United States in
the 19th century it involved among other
things
white Americans sort of emulating or
imitating and a derisive fashion the way
they thought like Americans act and act
it leads to the so called blackface mr.
C by the way I was just reading an
article that this suggests that
blackface minstrelsy is really making a
comeback in Australia of all places
interesting it of course it's made a
semi come back here not a strong
comeback I would today but a semi come
back and Jim Crow has descended to us as
the seminal or u.s. style of party
so-called separate-but-equal as I was
just making reference to separate Bibles
in the court room separate schools the
legacy of our historically black
colleges and universities for example
stem from the Jim Crow system such as
Texas Southern University in Houston
Texas which in some ways is right across
the street from University of Houston
it's a very stark legacy of the Jim Crow
era when you go to an Ivy League school
in the 1960s being black I think it
could either cause you to want to join
the u.s. ruling elite or to rebel
against the US ruling elite and I fell
into the second category that's an
interview you did on the real news
network
right yeah I went to Princeton and of
course as people often times see about
the military when you're in the military
you oftentimes you're fighting not
necessarily for the flag although I'm
sure that comes into account but you're
fighting for that buddy of yours and the
foxhole that's the way I look at
Princeton I mean I made some very good
friends there and you know these
universities they have a good thing
going because they they get people when
they're 17 or 18 they're first coming
into maturity and they leave leave it
very deep impression which it was why
Princeton was able to raise so much
money all these other Ivy League schools
because people that you get you get this
emotional attachment
because of your experiences at a place
like this it was often time said when
there was a search for Osama bin Laden
before he was killed that if he had been
alumnus of Princeton Princeton would a
family that he would mix in any
fundraising letters all the time so it
was a very good experience also in terms
of politics because I was involved in
the divestment movement let us say as
undergraduates we were protesting
Princeton University's ties sue
corporations invested and apartheid
South Africa so we occupied a building
and protest a Princeton ties to
apartheid South Africa I recall helping
to raise money for the students in
Orangeburg South Carolina who I believe
were killed in sort of 1969 and we
called driving money to a fundraiser in
Philadelphia so the money can be
distributed to the students but it
wasn't of course just all protests
paying at present of course I was going
to class as well and trying to do well
um although I must say being at
Princeton also primed me for what I'm
doing today because I recall when I was
in the classroom at Princeton in between
listening to the teacher and lecturing
I'd be plotting what I would be doing
succeeding weekend's say ok this weekend
I'll go to New York we can after that
I'll go to Philadelphia we can after
that I'll go to Washington now of course
I'm going to all these places to do
research I wasn't doing that of course
as an undergraduate person I was mostly
going to socialize so to speak so I have
to say I had a decent experience in
Princeton I must say how'd you get there
well that's a very good question um
what's happening at that moment which
actually gets us back to this research
is that there's pressure on the
institutions to desegregate
oh there's pressure coming from on high
to desegregate and Princeton of course
begins to seek out people like myself
now as it turns out I really didn't know
that much going about st. Louis I have
to confess even though I was reading
newspapers I mean when my first job was
maybe six or seven years old a paper
route so I used to read the st. Louis
post-dispatch although admittedly comic
strips in the sports page but still
because I was reading the sports page I
knew about Bill Bradley who at that time
was a basketball start Princeton and was
taking Princeton to the highest
stratosphere of the NCAA basketball
championships and use from Crystal City
Missouri which is not that far from st.
Louis and so even though I wasn't going
to play on the Princeton basketball team
I got captivated by the idea of
Princeton and then they came knocking on
my door and so I had to apply and Here I
am would your parents - in st. Louis my
father was a truck driver now my sisters
are saying Louis they'd like me to say
that my mother was a homemaker and
that's true
but I'd certainly recall her working
doing day work it was called working as
a maid home of affluent white I have a
distinct memory is that they're both
from Mississippi my mother from
Starkville Mississippi the home of
Mississippi State University and my
father from Columbus West Point
Mississippi it's the heart of darkness
when it comes to Dixie and Jim Crow I
grew up with stories about Mississippi
my mother usually don't tell me nothing
about Mississippi you have any stories
about you know having to get off the
sidewalk
if some whites are coming down the
sidewalk you have to step out
into the gutter and just these horror
stories about mr. I was I have to say
very nervous and apprehensive about
going to Mississippi for the longest and
I still have relatives there I've never
met because of nervousness now I have
gone to Oxford to do research this is
that a few weeks ago but I haven't
visited Mississippi as often as I should
still because of a certain nervousness
although I know that that's probably
unrealistic that attitude that I have
but still it's still somewhere buried in
my consciousness so my father is a truck
driver he was a member of the Teamsters
Union which used to bill itself as the
largest Union not only United States but
in a capitalist world and I used to read
their publications because they would be
mailed to our house and subsequently but
not then I've become fascinated with the
st. Louis Teamsters because they had a
very interesting leadership Harold
Gibbon now of course the thing with the
Teamsters or union that's understandably
unjustifiably known for corruption and
organized crime ties but st. Louis was
somewhat different
Harold Gibbons was something of a social
democrat and then he helped to then he
work with other black leaders of the
Teamsters like Ernest Callaway for
example so that's the sort of
working-class environment that I grew up
with rockin the st. Louis which I'm sure
it led to me developing the subspecialty
of labor history Gerald Horne in the arc
of US history in your view how
significant is the 2008 election I think
it's very significant uh now it's true
that many overstated the case perhaps
understandably
this idea of a post-racial Society for
example was a clear overstatement but
given the us torturous path of
enslavement of Africans and Jim Crow
it's not actually
it's it's it's earth-shattering its
earth-shaking that a black president was
elected although if there's a long
textual footnote in my 1776 book that
deals with the diverse origins of black
Americans and I put forward the idea
that there's been a special persecution
of the descendants of enslaved Africans
in North America which is not to say
that blacks from an immigrant background
like Barack Obama have escaped
persecution as a matter of fact I can't
wait to read the memoir literature from
this administration because I'm sure
we'll be reading many stories about the
kind of disrespect that he received as
the first black president which I think
had foreign policy consequences in terms
of if foreigners born leaders are saying
at the peep of these powerful elements
in the United States don't respect them
why should i but having said that I
don't find it accidental that's the
first black president is from an
immigrant background as opposed to the
descendant of enslaved Africans me for
example the activist and professor
Angela Davis talks about growing up in
Birmingham Alabama this is in a book
called dreamy and french by alice kaplan
where she says that in order to try to
evade these strictures of Jim Crow in
Birmingham he would go into the distorts
speak French and then they would not
perceive her as a descendant of it slave
African or uh there I'm writing this
book about aviation so there's this
black pilot who's born in Trinidad and
Tobago he talks about how he's able to
escape the more egregious strictures of
Jim Crow in Dixie by affecting this
British auxins for example therefore
he's not perceived as the descendant of
enslaved Africans or take the singer
babs Gonzalez born Lee Brown in Newark
New Jersey but he feels that if he takes
the main Babson's all
he will not be to see the descendants of
enslaved that mean that all these
stories from the Jim Crow era a black
Americans masquerading as African
princes and passing all kinds of
different ways of course I wrote this
book about passing about Lawrence Denis
who went on to be the leader of u.s.
fascism who pass for white quote-unquote
he was light-skinned obviously and he
spoken this sort of very cold what we
would call a cultured accent which helps
to him to evade the reality that he was
actually born in Jim Crow Atlanta and
born as a young Negro but his heart out
here being a Negro particularly men and
so he crosses the color line so yes 2008
was no doubt a turning point in terms of
US history although I think it was David
Axelrod of Barack Obama's advisor who
wrote in The New York Times some months
ago that in the largest scheme scheme of
things you can see the rise of Donald J
Trump a sort of a counter-reaction to
Barack Obama just as the rise of Barack
Obama in some ways is a counter-reaction
to George W Bush that is to say this
so-called cowboy foreign policy to more
anti-war stance and more urbane
cosmopolitanism as opposed to the
rough-hewn ways in Crawford Texas and
then of course the cavalry action
leading to the rise of Donald J Trump
Gerald Horne has taught at City College
of New York Sarah Lawrence College UC
Santa Barbara University of Zimbabwe UNC
Chapel Hill the University of Hong Kong
and since 2003 has been professor of
history an African American University
of Houston after he graduated from
Princeton he went on to get his law
degree from UC Berkeley a master's from
Columbia and a PhD from Columbia as well
we've talked for an hour now it's your
turn
phone numbers are up on the screen if
you can't get through on the phones
try social media we
filter through those addresses as well
David here in Washington DC you're the
first call hi David hello how are you
today
yes dr. Horne my question is I would
like to ask could you explain to your
viewing audience the role of Haiti in
the finding of United States leave yes
David why is that a question why is that
of interesting well the interest because
they don't talk about the significance
of the Haitian Revolution and his
influence on African Americans and the
United States and the founding of the
United States and that question needs to
be addressed thank you thank you always
a pleasure sir thank you well thank you
for that question
I'm always happy to talk about Haiti it
was the subject of my book confronting
black jacobins which just came out last
year and in that book my major argument
is that the Haitian Revolution 1791 to
1804 that rarest of events a successful
result of successful revolt of the in
Slade ignited a general crisis of the
entire slave system in the Americas that
could only be resolved with its collapse
therefore we in the United States
particularly the descendants of enslaved
Africans Oh an eternal debt of gratitude
to Haiti that can never be successfully
repaid that's the point that's not only
made by me was made by a Frederick
Douglass the great 19th century
abolitionist was made by wev Dubois who
of course had roots in Hispaniola now
oftentimes when the Haitian Revolution
is discussed it's discussed in terms of
France the defeated colonial power on
the island deciding to liquidate its
interests in North America leading
directly to the Louisiana Purchase of
1803 which helps to expand the
boundaries of the United States of
America with the Louisiana Purchase
engineered by Thomas Jefferson I usually
don't take that approach although I
mention it in my book because I think
too often US historians gives short
shrift to Native American history and
give short shrift to the land theft that
has bedeviled and beset
Native Americans this is a footnote I
noticed of the Baltimore Orioles
baseball games in reaction to the
controversy about standing or not naming
the national anthem they're starting to
play Woody Guthrie's Guthrie's this land
is your land in certain occasions which
is some ways is a step forward but in
other ways this land is your land and
some ways evades the question of
colonial settler colonialism and the
fact that this Native American plan
which oftentimes gets short-stroke but
in any case the Haitian Revolution like
successful revolutionaries it everywhere
in anywhere the Haitians try to spread
their revolutionary seditious gospel
it's possible to say that Gables revolt
in Virginia circa 1800 was it least
inspired by the Asian revolution slave
revolts for example in Barbados in 1816
which led written directly moving to
abolish slavery 1833 1834 inspired by
the Haitian Revolution as I talked about
in my book I also have a long footnote
in my book connecting Haitian Revolution
to the net turner slave revolt 1831 in
Virginia which is ignited almost 40
years to the day after August 1791 when
the Haitian Revolution is ignited
there's evidence to suggest that the
fleeing slave owners from Hispaniola
decamp to Virginia and many of the
Africans have a historical memory of
these folks fleeing in horror and in
desperation of course the movie Birth of
a Nation which I can't wait to see about
then that Turner revolt opens just in a
few days I'm going to be first in line
to see that moving from counterpunch
published this month or last month the
story and Gerald Horne explains why no
one should stand for the national anthem
asked if refusal to honor the u.s.
national anthem given its background and
surrounding history should be the norm
rather than the exception Horne replied
categorically and emphatically of course
first of all it provides cover for those
athletes who are courageously protesting
the national anthems not
only colin kaepernick who has received
death threats but Doug Baldwin
of the Seattle Seahawks has received
death threats athletes at the University
of Nebraska football team they protest
the national anthem the political elite
of Nebraska sought to reprimand and
rebuke them Indiana Fever women's
basketball team so we need to provide
support for these youth who are
courageously stepping forward second of
all as many have pointed out there's a
very disturbing lyrics in the third
stanza of the national anthem United
States of America which by the way as I
recall was not adopted as a national
anthem into the 20th century lyrics that
specifically appointed Leigh denounce
the black population of course national
anthem comes in the context of the war
of 1812 and if you follow what I said
about 1776 it should come as no surprise
that many of the enslaved Africans had a
choice between the dirty shirt of London
of the dirty t-shirt of Washington they
chose the dirty shirt including and up
to August 1814 when the Redcoats sacked
the city including the White House
sending President James Madison and his
garrulous palace dolly
leaing into the streets one step ahead
of the posse of course black Americans
were in solidarity with the invaders
many of these black Americans wind up
getting on ships and then sailing to
freedom and Trinidad and Tobago over
their descendants continued to reside in
fact I was giving a talk on the subject
in New York a few years ago and some of
the folks in the audience were
descendants of those Negroes who had
fled from the Chesapeake in August 1814
interestingly enough the propaganda of
Washington has been very successful a
leading professor whose name I will
spare you at an important University in
Washington DC just wrote that the
Negroes who sided with the British wound
up being reinsulate and that was the
line of course coming from James Monroe
etc I investigated some about book new
Google comers at the crown basically a
spurious claim but that shows you how
potent the
again that can be in any case the
national anthem there are many cases for
example after apartheid was dismantled
or defeated at the polls shall we say in
the spring of 1994 the South Africans
moved to adopt the new national anthem
you already see discussion about that in
this country people are saying god Bless
America
this land is your land America the
Beautiful in some ways the national
anthem or like it's like tree rings
which can be very revealing of what
befell this tree years ago with these
pointed lyrics aimed at black Americans
it reveals a certain kind of attitude
that I think often times people are
forgotten also I think that the national
anthem reveals another story it reveals
that you've had a certain integration
without transformation it reminds me of
the story about Capitol Hill a stone's
throw from where we're sitting where
when women start to arrive in in great
numbers there's not an attempt to
accommodate them by having more women's
bathrooms so there's integration of
women without transformation of the
landscape the national anthem reveals
that too often this country we've had a
certain kind of integration whereas
those who had been left out of the
bounty in the United States forced their
way in but then a sort of toll to adjust
to the contemporary reality when
actually what we need is transformation
if we're real really serious dr. Horne
double question why do we play the
national anthem at a sporting event it's
a private event private organization and
who cares what the second string
quarterback of the San Francisco 49ers
thinks about anything well actually in
the defense of Colin Kaepernick the
quarterback in question number seven I
was just talking with one of your
assistants who agree with me I'm asking
he should be starting of course Chip
Kelly the coach of the 49ers does not
have a very good reputation in that
regard in terms of dealing with black
athletes let
the record to go back and look at the
philadelphia inquirer
when he was coaching the Eagles for
example second of all colin kaepernick
is very intelligent in a man I've been
reading the stories about his tenure at
the University of Nevada in Reno and how
he was coming to consciousness a member
of the Kappa Alpha Phi fraternity by the
way a fraternity and my older brother
and Kansas City and I think that as long
as I agree I mean I'm not sure why it
should be played but as long as it is
going to be played then it provides a
platform I think for people like Colin
Kaepernick and Doug Baldwin and DeSean
Jackson of the Washington pro football
team who has designed these special
sneakers of cleats I should say that
he'll be wearing and protests in the
game today so they're going to give us
this platform I think we should take
next call for our guest comes from
Harold in Jackson Mississippi Harold
you're on the air thank you for this man
I think you're quite right about the
national anthem being a you know being a
necessary in private events but my
question was do you think the Republican
Party is the de facto right National
Party maybe it has been for a long time
is it ready to embrace that role so have
you well as I noted a few moments ago
that term white nationalism is being
revived paul krugman made reference to
it in this New York Times column just a
few days ago once again I find it
striking that that term does not emerge
from our friends to the left of
liberalism who in many ways have been
asleep at the switch when it comes to
analyzing the Trump phenomenon our
friends who are left of liberal they
keep urging people on the left not the
vote for the Greens Jill Stein even
though we know that the u.s.
presidential election is 51 different
elections those who get the most votes
no necessarily win is Al Gore to readily
tell you and despite the fact that
they're not paying attention to this
libertarian
where Gary Johnson's been endorsed by
the Chicago Tribune by the major Detroit
newspaper he's polling about 9 or 10
percent he presents a mortal threat to
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
and yet our friends on the Left are not
necessarily clamoring against the Gary
Johnson they're clamoring against Jill
Stein seems to me like it's misplaced
priorities but any case back to the
question I think we need a deeper
interrogation of this concept of white
nationalism now fortunately the scholars
have not been asleep at the switch on
this matter I think one of the most
encouraging aspects of us academia in
recent years has been the rise of the
whiteness literature that is to say
trying to ascertain how and why it was
that those who oftentimes are warring on
the shores of Europe English versus
French English versus Irish English
versus Scott serve versus Krotz German
versus British etc all of a sudden when
they cross the atlantic they're
magically transmuted into this white
identity the scholars have paid
attention to that but somehow in 2016
the lessons of that whiteness literature
have been lost which makes it which
helps to explain why so many folks have
been unable to explain or come to grips
with this Trump phenomenon not least the
support that he's receiving in places
like coal country in West Virginian
Eastern Kentucky etc as I wrote recently
some of our friends on the Left they're
parsing and torturing the numbers to an
extent that you would think the only
people were supporting Trump Rory vodka
and Donald Jr you have questions about
them even it's almost like the mythical
for instance of lecturer who says that I
know what you're saying is true in
practice the question is is it true in
theory in other words they have this
theory of the case with regard to how
this election should work itself out and
the fact that Trump has gotten so much
apparent working-class and middle-class
support disrupts their theory but they
stick to the theory nonetheless but I
guess we'll know on the
number eight whether or not they made a
misjudgment Nick Lake Hiawatha New
Jersey email professor horn do you in
your opinion do you believe the ecology
movement is looked upon as a Marxist
attempt to cure capitalist free-market
schemes of money profit over nature I'm
not sure if I understand that question
but I think they came up with the first
debate by Secretary Clinton that
apparently Donald J Trump has stated in
the past that he thought that the whole
argument about climate change was a way
was a scheme backed by China in order to
destabilize the United States certainly
it seems to me we need a discussion
about the so-called free market I think
that if you look and try to examine how
and why it is that there's so much
animosity and antipathy towards
government in the United States of
America not least the federal government
I think you can make a credible argument
that a lot of it has to do with the
aftermath of the u.s. Civil War I
oftentimes do this exercise with my
students because you know you know are
these students are nowadays when they're
in a class they're fiddling with their
laptops fiddling with their smartphones
etc have your half-cock to what you're
saying right maybe zero cocked and so I
go and snatch their smartphone and say
how would you feel if I take this
property of yours and don't compensate
you you'd be very upset and unhappy with
you of course they'd say yes well that's
what happened to the slave owners it was
one of the largest expropriations of
private property in history up to that
point of billions of dollars and
property in the slaved africans taken
without compensation leaving many
impoverished not only many impoverished
within the form of property the Africans
walking around all cheeky they I didn't
like you anyway which of course is very
enraging which leads inevitably to the
rise of the clock plant but also to the
scientifically to government which we're
still grappling with to this very day
I think these are the sorts of
discussions that we need if we're going
to try to figure out how the government
for example is going to execute measures
with regard to climate change this is
the recent agreement between China and
United States on the Paris agreement and
the recent agreement by the European
Union to take steps steps forward on the
Paris agreement
let's just want to involve government I
don't see how you're going to to escape
the potential calamity and catastrophe
that is climate change without
government involvement but with this
hostility to government in this country
it seems to me that we're getting
perilously close to this ideology
becoming a life-threatening
Victor Dayton Ohio you're on with
University of Houston history professor
Gerald Horne go ahead vicar greetings
you guys greetings professor Horne I
hope one day that you come to Ohio my
state or somewhere close by so I can get
you to sign the eight books that I
bought from you and my dictionary I want
you to sign that too because your prose
is definitely elaborate could you share
some of the technical challenges that
you often encountered in your research
especially in America I noticed in the
process of a counter revolution of 1776
the issue with Daniel Parrish jr.
slavery transcript I'd like to hear that
now the second question is how can we
get the prophetic myths that are
mandated as truth in history in American
schools College high school elementary
middle school out of here eliminated I
mean is this this to me is just Victor
what one of those are no that's baby
Victor what's one of the myth the myth
the myth of the very Constitution it was
written to support slavery the myth of
the founding of America is dr. Horne
clearly shows in 17th counter revolution
of 1776 the the myths about the the war
with Mexico them just I mean it's just a
plethora of
yes thank you things like your tractor
horn well with regard to the dentin of
the Paris transcripts at the New York
Historical Society in Manhattan which is
a very good source or slavery by the way
particularly slavery from say the
Glorious Revolution 1688 up through the
early national period the early 19th
century in the United States of America
it's a very good source but in the
introduction a note that after I've made
Afghan encountered this source which
becomes a source from my 1776 book I
exit the New York Historical Society on
Central Park West in Manhattan and of
course being Mellon enriched I have
difficulty flagging down a taxi and then
I go into this little antidote about how
like our ancestors
I turned to negative note positive so I
started walking and getting exercise
caring team that I live to fight another
day and then I made an analogy to when I
lived in Hong Kong in the latter point
of the 20th century when the taxi
drivers used to pass by Chinese to pick
me up now that's only because they
thought I was probably a fluent tourist
who had given him a nice tip maybe a
diplomat or something like that old on
the way I was dressed I'm sure did not
give that attitude but I went into this
riff about how with the rise of China in
the 21st century when another major
issue that many of our black leaders and
intellectuals are not grappling with
what impact would that have on the black
condition in North America now with
regard to difficulties in archives John
Hope Franklin the latest story and used
to talk about the difficulty he had in
black historian in doing research
because of course segregation means you
can't necessarily come in the archive
and so it hampers the ability of these
historians to do their research and to
tell the tale which is one of the
reasons why it's my generation that
should be should be in the vanguard
because we ten
we have access although I can remember
an episode at the University of
Washington in Seattle when I was doing
research had this activist was giving me
such a hard time which is different us
you know my rule in the archives is so
the archivist is always right is there
any questions about that revert to rule
one the octopus is always right so I
couldn't understand so finally I just
left that it felt sort of harassed
fortunately that has not been the norm
although I've had difficulties in
certain archives remember ones going to
Antigua and Caribbean they wouldn't let
me in to do my research for whatever
reason with regard to Ohio I'll be
visiting Ohio sometime next year because
I'm doing this book on southern Africa
and there's a at Oberlin College in Ohio
there's an interesting collection about
Mozambique that I want to consult
dealing with the founding father modern
Mozambique Eduardo man Lonnie who of
course study in the United States before
founding the now ruling party and
Mozambique so I'll be visiting there
actually I was there just the summer I
was at the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
they have a very good archive there in
Cleveland it's very good archive because
I'm doing this Jazz Studies book and the
papers of a chimeric to God Turkish
American will have to found Atlantic
Records and soared into the highest
ranks of the US really elite becoming
fabulously affluent or there and of
course Atlantic Records recorded many
jazz artists so it's a very revealing
archive there professor Horne you've
written 31 books it sounds like you're
working on three or four right now
what's your what's your process my
process well I guess it starts with the
idea and sometimes the idea is it comes
from conversations that you have with
people or with a cell need me for
example the 1776 book was definitely
response to a felt need as I saw it
oh then of course their interest I mean
I I wrote two books
film because I've watched lots of movies
and I felt that it just made no sense
just to watch all these movies and not
turn it into something um I listen to
music jazz all the time so this thing's
me it didn't make any sense to listen to
this music all the time and not write
something about it and I really liked it
here's another crowdsource idea I really
like to do a book about baseball anybody
has any ideas I mean I I'm in touch with
the archivist at the Baseball Hall of
Fame in Cooperstown
but I'm lacking an idea so you have to
come up with an idea and you have to
have as a historian I can't make I'm not
novel as I just can't make things up so
I have to find sources for what I'm
writing about which involves dealing
with archives and archivists and then
you know you take notes of course to
take notes you have to have some sort of
idea what you're going to write about I
think that's one of the reasons that
helps explain why many historians of
1776 I've ignored the what used to be
called a Negro question because they
didn't take notes in the new system so
therefore they can't write about they
don't write about it and so then you
take notes and then you print out your
notes and then try to organize it into
chapters and then write Emily is calling
in from Boulder Colorado please go ahead
Emily I've never called into a show but
I watch a book TV a lot I've learned a
lot from bikini but I did notice an
error earlier and I'd like to discuss
that second and like a brief write about
Francis Scott Key the author of the
star-spangled banner and I learned this
from both Cleary there was the brother
of Roger tawny the former chief justice
yes of Dred Scott ill-fame right and
that's another reason we should choose
another son what was the error is yet
anywhere we go I noticed that this is
spreading and the more people who hear
it the more it will spread and a Peter
slant and Geralyn huh both mispronounced
the name Robson
sorry I have stage fright I grew up in a
left-wing household I heard his name
frequently as a child I met him when I
was 5 years old a wasted opportunity to
follow up on a valuable contact on me so
we're not on pronounce that correctly
it's two syllables Robson and I'd like
to just very briefly list a few people
who have talked about him in
documentaries and in other context
Lloyd Brown his friend Ghost Rider
chauffeur and biographer I was a friend
of Lloyd's for years before the end of
his life and he always said ropes and
not Robeson also pull jr. I met him I
worked on the world labels at the New
York Historical Society when they did
the centenary exhibition on Robson in
1998 after I saw the exhibition I
noticed well while I was reading them I
noticed errors I worked in book
publishing at the time and that was my
job but they allowed me to do some
Corrections and that's how I met Paul
jr. Martin Doberman a biographer of
ropes and I've heard him speak on book
TV teach sugar Harry Belafonte
under-represent
they all use the what I consider the
correct pronunciation two syllables all
right
Emily thank you Emily sounds pretty
fascinating we I will refer for now on
to Paul Robeson absolutely guilty I
think that that may come from
pronunciations I've heard of Robeson
County in North Carolina that led infect
the correct pronunciation
I knew Lord Brown I think he's passed
away by now as a matter of fact for many
reasons I regret that Lord Brown passed
away he was he too was a barter for Paul
and so and that's because for a while I
was thinking about doing a book on the
relations between
Germany and black Americans which has
been quite extensive but not necessarily
covered extensively and that's the
background of Lloyd Brown that is to say
from the German and an african-american
heritage a new paul jr who's passed away
oh and it is dual bog raphy - volume
biography Oh
his father it's quite good because often
times you run into people who have a
famous relatively sir they're going to
do a book it never gets done or if it
gets done it's not adequate to the task
but Paul's juniors due to volume
biography is very good professor Horne
did the n-double-a-cp start out as a
radical organization so that's a fair
assessment particularly if you consider
that their founding in 1909 involved a
collaboration between black Americans
such as to BB Dubois or Du Bois and many
socialists and of course Du Bois himself
considered himself a socialist at the
time but this was not necessarily
unusual because as I tried to suggest in
the preceding minute it's not as if Jim
Crow was an unpopular cause that is to
say by those who did not have to suffer
under slings and arrows but the
n-double-a-cp as I say in my first book
on which is on Du Bois black and red uh
it has to go through turmoil during the
Red Scare and cold war they purge Dubois
with he had served with the
n-double-a-cp from 1909 to 1934 had a
falling out with the organization goes
to teach at Atlanta University where he
pins his magnificent tone black
reconstruction which is the so called
revisionist take on the post-civil war
era which is remind us all if we need
reminding
that the job one job of historians is
revising history and telling a different
story based on Newton's reputations and
new sources something that's oftentimes
lost light up but Dubois is purged after
he comes back to the n-double-a-cp
during the halcyon days of 1944 the days
of the anti-fascist Arab the days when
Soviet Union and the United States were
on the same side fighting Germany then
Japan he's the director Foreign
Relations but 1948 the Red Scare is
underway Dubois
does not is not interested in supporting
harry s truman which is the line taken
by many of the leaders in the
double-a-c-p including walter white and
Roy Wilkins he supported for Henry a
Wallace who was considered one of the
closest friends of the Negro being a FDR
vice president in 1940 a secretary of
agriculture for example in fact by
Truman
circa 1946 he was a third-party
candidacy progressive party robust
Robeson supports Henry a Wallace as well
and this leads to concessions anti Jim
Crow concessions Truman moves
officially to desegregate the military
but the question is was the price too
high because their compromises and then
their compromises there are certain
compromises then leave you in an
advantageous position to march forward
and there are certain other compromises
that are crippling and my historical
estimate is that the ouster of the left
and the radicals and people like boys
from n-double-a-cp is a crippling
handicapping compromise from which the
n-double-a-cp and the black movement has
yet to recover I would say the same
thing about the labor movement which I
went through a similar purge purging
people like Harry Bridges who I
mentioned Ferdinand Smith who was a
Jamaican migrant who becomes the
second-in-command of National Maritime
Union then he's of course a radical as
well he's purged and then sent back to
Jamaica where he becomes a leader of the
labor
an independence movement in Jamaica but
this has it seems to me a devastating
impact on the US working class you can
draw a straight line from those purges
it seems to me in 2016 and the struggles
the afl-cio is having in places like
Youngstown Ohio and Eastern Kentucky and
coal country in West Virginia and trying
to convince working-class people not to
vote for Donald J Trump and it also has
a devastating impact on the black
working class leaving this sector of the
working class idiot lots are like
unprepared the deal with globalization
robot ization International challenges
at cetera that's my own historical
estimate of course there are many who
disagree Omar Sacramento California
thanks for holding you're on with
Professor Gerald Horne yes thank you
that's hard for me to convey my question
to you and also want to say to c-span
thank you for book TV very enlightening
beautiful conversation thank you very
much I had a question about a book I've
read by Daniel resolution book called
the American uprising untold story of
the largest slave revolt as supposedly a
revolt that took place in New Orleans
1811 and he asserts that feed this
revolution this revolt was responsible
for actually the establishment of the
United States because of the troops that
were brought down at the time and
established nearing that in that part of
the country and I wonder if you could
maybe she had some light on that and
just give you some more context because
it is asserted but many people are
taught to know nothing about this
revolution is supposed to be so anyways
I just wanted if you can shed some light
on that yeah I like that book um as I
recall it was a Harvard undergraduate
thesis that was turned into a book and
many historians have sniffed at the book
but I think it's I think it's
significant of this this revolt of the
enslaved that takes place in Louisiana
as the caller says circa 18
carries a reputation of being one of the
more significant revolts of the enslaved
and the history of the United States I
talked about that particular revolt in
my Haitian Revolution book because many
of the Africans who were involved in
that revolt had come to Louisiana after
their so-called masters had fled with
them from Hispaniola to Louisiana but
once again having seen slave owners
fleeing horror at the sight of angry
Africans these Africans were inspired to
try to emulate the Haitian Revolution I
think it also comes up in my Negril
comrade to the crown book as well if I'm
not mistaken now with regard to its
impact on the founding and stateful
measure with the colored men since the
United States
it's found in late 18th century oh so
I'm not sure what with the color meant
by that
every guest we have here on in depth we
ask him or her to supply a list of their
favorite writers what they're reading
now some of their influences we want to
show you professor horns answers to
those questions
[Music]
by travelpod member
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
book TV tapes hundreds of author
interview programs throughout the
country all year long here's a look at
some of the events we'll be covering
this week on Tuesday at the seminary
co-op bookstore in Chicago attorney
William De Marchi
will discuss the life of Judge Richard
Posner then on Wednesday
at the Carnegie Council for ethics in
international affairs in New York City
Yale University professor Akhil Reed
amar will provide a modern history of
the US Constitution Thursday at Harvard
bookstore in Cambridge Massachusetts
Nancy Malkiel former dean of the college
at Princeton University will look at the
decision for many colleges and
universities to go co-ed at the end of
the 1960s and on Friday we're back in
New York at the Union League club where
James Rosen and Christopher Buckley will
discuss a collection of essays by the
late author and founder of the National
Review William F Buckley that's a look
at some of the author programs book TV
is covering this week many of these
events are open to the public look for
them to air in the near future on book
TV on c-span to
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and our conversation with dr. Gerald
horn continues here on book TV in depth
202 is the area code seven four eight
8200 is live in the east and central
time zone seven four eight eight two
zero one for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific time zones several
ways of getting hold of us via social
media as well book TV at c-span org is
our email address at book TV is our
Twitter handle and you can also make a
comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV that you
listed surely Graham Dubois book Zulu
heart as one of your favorites who was
she well she was a black woman born the
latter part of the 19th century passing
away interestingly enough in China in
the mid to late 1970s in between she was
a writer of operas writer of novels
Sagra fees a functionary with
n-double-a-cp office but she's probably
better known as the spouse of Debbie B
Dubois her the second right the same as
she was the second wife of WB Dubois and
it was with him that she sorted to
further prominence to a degree that is
to say that they migrated to Ghana West
Africa in 1961 Ghana coming to
independence in 1957 under the
leadership of Kwame Nkrumah and the WB
Dubois was slated to organize the so
called encyclopedia Africana after he
passed away 1963 as she became the
director of Ghana television and was
trying to do some interesting
experiments with the use of television
and converting into something perhaps as
elevated and intelligent and influential
as c-span believe it or not and
unfortunately for her the inclement
government was overthrown circa nineteen
sixty-six interesting enough the
ambassador at that time was Franklin
Williams who was a formidable a sepia
fish
black American who then Graham Dubois
and kuma etc of course blamed him to a
degree for the hill for throw of his
government was interesting confluence of
this these two lines in the black
movement that is to say one trying to
oppose u.s. foreign policy namely
Shirley Graham Dubois and the others
supporting us namely Franklin Williams
in any case she migrates to Eagle and
lives in Cairo but then she becomes a
devoted follower of Maoist China which
helps to explain why she dies in China
and to a certain degree is still
celebrated in China but her novel Zulu
hard it's a fictionalized version of the
fact that heart transplants you may
recall were carried out in South Africa
by dr. Christian Barnard so she is sort
of a science fiction some ways
reminiscent of a coke Octavia Butler the
great science fiction writer also passed
away insofar as the people who get the
Zulu hearts they're sort these European
settlers they're transform when they hit
targets of Zulus but I've missed that
book also not only because I could talk
about Sheila Graham Dubois but also it's
sort of a stand-in for an interests I
have and creative writing creative
stories filmmaking screenplay writing
etc but got to ask you about a book
you're currently reading sex workers
psychics
and number runners by LaShawn Harris yes
she's a young black woman historian at
the Michigan State University we were
sitting on a panel at NYU just a few
months ago and she was kind and gracious
enough to give me a copy of her book and
as so often happens when someone so
generous to me I feel compelled to read
it but in this case I'm learning a lot
it's a very intriguing story it should
win awards I'll probably see her in a
few days that the conference I mentioned
a few months ago moments ago in Richmond
Virginia and at the panel we were on she
was talking about marvel cook who was a
black woman journalist for the New York
Amsterdam news who provides some of the
source material for some of her stories
about sex workers numbers runners
cetera in New York right in New York
Amsterdam news of 1930s marvel cook was
also close to the family of Roy Wilkins
even though they were a different sides
of the ideological barricades only
passing away a few years ago I recommend
that book highly it's part of the
marvelous list that comes to us courtesy
of the University of Illinois press well
let's go back to phone calls for Gerald
Horne Jim's in Toledo Ohio hi Jim Jim I
have to put you on hold till you turn
down the volume on your phone and
reminder that you're going to hear a
delay if you keep your TV up when you
answer the phone
Diane's in st. Petersburg Florida hi
Diane hi thank you thank you dr. Horne
for this wonderful program today and
thanks to book TV my question is do you
have any insights into the new
Smithsonian Museum of african-american
history for example does it really
represent the level of brutality
suffered by African slaves well sadly
unfortunately though I'm here in
Washington I have not had the
opportunity to visit this museum
understand that it's very hard to get
admission understand that you can't get
a mission before January or later so but
I have followed the press coverage of
the museum and just speaking from 30,000
feet that is to say not with particular
informed insight into the exhibits
because I haven't visited but speaking
the level generalization it seems to be
a victory that is to say that the fact
that the torturous journey of people of
African descent and North America is
being recognized now does it represent
the atrocities I'm not sure although I
will say that's coming back to the
second version of route
I think the second version of routes is
really graphically violent
and personally compared to the first
version of the 1970s and I'm not sure
why that is
I'm not sure if it's because it was
downplayed in 1970s or people were more
willing to accept violence on the screen
in 2016 but the violence and the roots
that I've seen so far is it's rather
stark but once again the ultimate test
it passes that's reflective of reality
because if you look at the
advertisements for runaway slaves for
example which is a major source for
historians you oftentimes fine slave
owners will say you know missing all is
his front teeth only has one ear only
has one arm yeah in terms of
distinguishing marks that will help this
person be recovered which obviously be
speaks a certain kind of brutality which
is also reflected in the slave
narratives as well which talked at great
length about the brutality of course you
recall the Frederick Douglass the great
abolitionist zero from this metropolitan
area I spoke at lists not only about the
violence but about how confronting
violence is a necessary part of his
growth as a human being and the
development of his psyche what do you
think about the movie something you've
referenced in your books Gone with the
Wind
yeah interestingly enough here's a tip
to researchers actually I just gave this
tip to a journalist I was at the
University of Georgia at Athens just a
few weeks ago where the papers of
Margaret Mitchell the author of that
book are cited and I was looking through
the mark of Mitchell papers to see how
Gone with the Wind was received in
southern Africa I was received in South
Africa of course we received a rapturous
reception at least amongst the a
separate population ditto for Rhodesia
but the mark of Mitchell papers has
quite a bit on how was received all over
the world it would be a very useful
project if it hasn't you know knowing
scholars it probably already has been
done but I was thinking the time
somebody should go through the market
Richard Mitchell papers and talk about
how that novel was received overseas bad
I have to say I'm not a fan
with the wind I think it presents a sort
of moonlight and magnolias version of
slavery a sort of glorified version
romanticized version of this horrible
institution it helps to solidify in my
opinion the support for Jim Crow there
was existing obtaining and Atlanta and
in short at that time and by the way
strikingly enough and land and Georgia
was founded circus 1732 as a so-called
white colony no Negroes allow not least
because the Negroes were always trying
to align with the Spanish in Florida
particularly in st. Augustine she upset
South Carolina and points northward
including the prize that was Virginia so
Georgia was going to be this great wall
separating Spanish Florida from South
Carolina Virginia and North Carolina the
points northward but it didn't work out
very well obviously since the 2010
census showed that Atlanta and/or and
Georgia has one of the most significant
black populations in North America and
it didn't work out as well also because
it was hard to find people to work in
the fields and plus it was reintroduced
into class contradictions when you have
Europeans and the fields and Europeans
in the big house it disrupts the white
you might expect and in any case the
slave traders in North America were past
masters of smuggling so they were it
just was quite a powerful incentive to
smuggle Africans and to Georgia because
the African slave trade was one of the
most lucrative enterprises known to
humankind
you could invest $1 and get $1,800 back
with that kind of profit of course a
slave trader would sell their firstborn
not to mention some African that they
did not know so in any case I recommend
the market Mitchell papers at the
University of Georgia at Athens
they're quite well organized the
archivists there have done a very good
job they're very friendly to by the way
so a visit there must not be avoided dr.
Horne there's a good chance that if he
flew into National Airport here in why
you took Jefferson Davis Highway into
into DC there's an effort to rename it
well bully for though me as long overdue
it's quite striking that those who try
to overthrow the US government and
inflict help to inflict hundreds of
thousands of casualties on this land
more casualties than in World War two
the United States suffered more
casualties than and Vietnam by several
orders of magnitude and yet they're
celebrating now as I've tried to explain
the story and as the historians have not
done a very good job of explaining those
in 1861 and the so-called Confederate
States of America felt that they were
walking the footsteps of 1776 that is to
say that there was secession from the
British Empire in 1776 because in
Somerset's case in 1772
London seemed to be moving towards
abolition of slavery rather than accept
that decision the extinction of profits
that it pretended they rebelled and
kicked out London then in 1836 you have
Texas secession from Mexico after Mexico
had moved to abolish slavery a few years
early of course Mexico later president
of African descent Vicente Guerrero 180
years before the election of Barack
Obama the secessionists succeeded of
course they had to then come crawling
back to join in on States of America in
1845 because Britain in Haiti it put so
much pressure on them that they thought
that they would be overthrown and
liquidated
so they joined in on States then in 1861
another secession to preserve slavery
and so I think it's an assent it's
understandable why there are these
symbols of the Confederacy that's still
pockmark the landscape because they
thought that they were just continuing
1776 and of course the historians have
tried to tell the story about how no
they weren't trying to continue 1776
actually even though we know as one of
your caller said that the Constitution
was not designed to have lift Africans
to put it mildly but somehow those
principles or eternal which is like
saying the principles of apartheid that
have lifted poor afrikaners in the 1940s
per the suggestion of the Carnegie
Corporation of New York by the way we're
also designed to look Nelson Mandela so
he says just waiting
instead of forming spirit of nation on
Kunta way sees way and leaving a
military campaign leading to his being
imprisoned you should follow the example
and just wait for these principles to
flower like mushrooms after a spring
rain I mean this barely passes the
giggle test but this is what our
children are taught which is one of the
reasons according to perspectives the
newsletter of American Historical
Association their headquarters is right
here in Washington within walking
distance of the studio enrollment of
college students history classes
continue to go down because you know
these Millennials these young people did
not find the stuff
and the historians or seem unable to
change they're not necessarily adhering
to market signals they say on Wall
Street there is a saying amongst
economists that the field progresses one
funeral at a time as to say as these
older economists die off then younger
economists can take their place and
advance the field which hopefully will
help us to understand the Great
Recession of 2007-2008 some day the
problem in a field like history is that
the nature of peer review in the way
that historians are trained guarantees
that the older historians or training
people just like themselves right before
they expire which means that the
mythology continues to be perpetuated
thus far Kenneth in Santa Rosa
California email even though I'm
troubled by his overall indictment of
racism in the US DNA I'm more troubled
by his embrace of socialism question if
socialism is such a blessing
why not the mass migration of American
blacks and those Houston Nigerian
immigrants he mentioned to the socialist
paradises of Cuba and Venezuela that's a
very good question I think that
socialism
suffered a blow obviously Cuba suffered
a blow when the socialist camp in
Eastern Europe collapsed but on a level
generalization I would just repeat what
I just said that the French novelist
Balzac suggests that that be here behind
every great fortune there is a great
crime I would suggest that behind every
great nation there's a great crime and
particularly if you look at a nation
like the United States I don't think we
lose anything by pointing through the
rapacious nature of this country in its
history particularly how it's been
devan's dissent in particular now with
regard to Cuba I'll always be in debt to
Cuba like I'm in debt to Haiti and the
reason is you may recall them when
Nelson Mandela had his funeral in
December 2013 dying at the age of 95
then only a few heads of state were
allowed to speak one of which was
rebroadcast row of Cuba and that's
because of their row a Cuban role in
helping to liberate southern Africa in
fact I was just at the Gerald Ford
Library in Ann Arbor going through the
papers of Henry Kissinger and these
other characters and in July 1975 this
is right before Angolan Independence
which Cuba helped the safeguard that
same year Kissinger and his staff were
running around with their head on hair
on fire because they're worried that the
Cuban troops might intervene in Rhodesia
and then march all the way to Pretoria
so they stay prepared legal memorandum
which suggested that the Cuban troops
might be justified in going to Rhodesia
now Zimbabwe but would not be justified
in going to South Africa but this was
what people were thinking about and I
dare say that one of the reasons why the
ANC government the African National
Congress government in South Africa the
party of Nelson Mandela has had so much
difficulty in constructing what they had
promised the voters in the spring of
1994 was I think we've all
underestimated we decisive role of
Cubans and bringing the apartheid rulers
to the tape
but the Cubans were not necessarily
involved in constructing the post 1994
South African society which is obvious
which is one of the reasons why Raul
Castro of Cuba was one of the few heads
of state who spoke at Nelson Mandela's
funeral and so I think that Cuba is
obviously having difficulties and I
could make one more point about Cuba
okay this speaks to press coverage
because with the normalization of Obama
which is one of the signal victories in
terms of diplomacy including a recent
article in The New Yorker I think about
John Lee Anderson so it's always
portrayed as the United States as being
benevolent - poor little Cuba when
actually if you study this question what
you'll find is that the United States as
evidenced by Barack Obama's attempt to
reset with Moscow before February 2014
the Crimea intervention and pivot
towards China is very much concerned
about the rise of China
you might recall the right before the
sunnylands summit in Southern California
with Obama and Xi Jinping of China
President Xi had met with all the
Caribbean leaders and two hundred and
tobago Chinese investment is flooding
into Bahamas says self just off the tip
of southern Florida the United States
has good reason to have normalized
relations with Cuba in order to avoid
and evade another October 1962 crisis
such as when Moscow was accused of
placing missiles they called the
sensitive in Cuba to safeguard Cuba from
invasion to the United States the United
States has very good strategic reasons
right now to have normalized relations
with Cuba in the broader context of
things and their ongoing contestation
with China which will be lasting for
some years to come that's sorely missing
from the mainstream US press which is
that they're already training though
they're helping poor little Cuba is its
fairy tales for children Barbra Newark
New Jersey please go ahead with your
question or comment for general tones
and so I have a comment and then a
question
eg as long as those Carboni iron in it
as long as there is a criminal element
iron of it and as long as those but one
fell in jail I am not free until we all
have a consciousness of connectedness
install of our ego and drama and our
desire for excessive money fame and
power we will have comparisons and I
identity conflict is there any way he
thinks
that we can have consciousness where
instead of our identities as race or
class or whatever family we ever have a
complete connection and consciousness
and then we have validity self solidity
in a paradoxical sense of all being
connected and then I wanted to ask a
question about Maya Angelou health or
history okay you know what we're going
to leave it at that first question and
so we can get some more calls in
professor Horne well a number of
questions have come in along those lines
which is what is to be done how can we
move forward progressively which is
obviously an excellent question and the
only thing I would say is that after
studying and writing about the great
scope of black American history
over the centuries then at least two
lessons jump out at me
one is the necessity for organization
and I would say the same holds true not
only for black people but for Latinos
asian-americans and Native Americans
were working climbs for feminists and
second internationalism that is the
slavery can cross the borders and
reaching across the oceans because one
of the points that leaps out at you with
regard to black American history in
particular is how so often the
correlation of forces the balance of
forces were so tilted against us that in
order to counter veil
that negative imbalance domestically we
have to have global and international
alliances and that's one of the things
that's missing now I dare say that it's
a lesson that I would hope the black
lives matter movement studies very
carefully and intensively David San
Francisco good afternoon
yes thank you dr. Horne I was so
thrilled to see your name come up on the
in-depth calendar because one of my
proudest political actions in my life
was voting for you for Vice President on
the Ron Daniels ticket in 1992 not just
in the November election but at the
Peace and Freedom Party nominating
convention in August of that year in San
Diego so I just wanted to lay that on
you and find out what you think about
that in 1992 your memories and how you
think it might relate to today and the
whole lesser evil thing so thank you
very much David what do you do in San
Francisco sorry what do you do in San
Francisco oh I'm just an office worker
thank you sir well actually I ran for US
Senate from the state of California in
1992 I was chairman chairman [ __ ]
uppity subscrive party
I enjoyed that immensely um because when
you're running for office people think
they can come up to you and talk to you
about anything I mean literally anything
about personal problems family problems
history politics whirl so I've learned a
lot this from talking to people got
three hundred and five thousand votes by
the way I'll just mention two quantity
not the percentage is California
correctly and contrary to the propaganda
that we have particularly hear from our
friends on the left it did not allow the
Republican to prevail I mean Dianne
Feinstein won it was her first term
she's whatever Sun she's telling us in
2016
um so I think there's a lesson there
somewhere and I did particularly well
I'm proud to say amongst black voters
black American voters let's think
appreciated
having put one of their own
quote-unquote so they throw its hat into
the ring but such a high office which of
course is very unusual because what was
your platform well you know it's
interesting so you'll have the t-shirts
from that era and I recall we had a
French horn in the shape of a horn of
plenty in our cornucopia cute and of
course free college tuition we
anticipated that for public institutions
which now Bernie Sanders or Hillary
Rodham Clinton or Kelton of course
Medicare for all of course cutting the
Pentagon budget dramatically slashing it
applying it to human needs which
presupposes of non interventionist
foreign policy shutting down these
scores of military bases the United
States has all over the world and claim
that those months to human need some of
those are the basic planks on the
platform what does it cost to go to the
University of Houston for a year yikes I
can't remember
a question I can't answer gladly enough
rosemarys in Penn Valley California and
rosemary you're on book TV on c-span 2
hi hi well thank you so much
my question is perhaps similar to the
lady from New Jersey it's about not to
negate any history or facts but just
what would dr. horns idea be about what
the scientists say that we are all from
Africa originally and so as far as black
and white or any other ethnicity goes
were all mixed and you know is that like
a believable thing and also how it
applies to our President Obama who he's
termed black president our first black
president and but he's biracial and
Michelle referred to him as biracial
just recently on the national news
and so why is he black not white because
he's my president
I'm predominantly white but um you know
getting ready to do that 23andme because
my aunt said she did it and we have
african-american ethnicity and that's my
question I'd like to know what dr. horns
and horns ideas about rosemary in Penn
Valley California
well these terms to start off on this
level historically constructed what I
mean is that for various historical
reasons the United States has adhere to
the so called one-drop rule we do say
that you can look like the RTW bush or
Madonna but if you have quote one drop
of African blood and quote that means
you're black and of course as I've told
my students the University of Houston
this facilitates slavery because you
could have a Irish person getting off
the boat in New Orleans and in 1850s and
it's kit now you say I'm not a slave yes
you are you know you look like this
slave right over here so so obviously it
expands the boundary for slavery
secondly it helps to denigrate blackness
which then facilitates the further
exploitation of black labor not only pre
Civil War post-civil war with the rise
of the so-called convict lease system
where black people were arrested on
spurious grounds and then leased out the
major corporations for profit making
purposes and of course equating like
people with criminal which is one of the
reasons we still have so many problems
in terms of these police killings
because this equation of blackness with
criminality with regard to whiteness
thanks to David wall Stryker colleague
at the City University of New York
Graduate Center who when I was writing
my 1776 book turned to me went to the
secondary source that talks about the
origins of the construction of whiteness
according to the secondary source of
course it comes up in the context of the
further expansion of the Americas the
expropriations of Native Americans
enslavement of Africans because if you
think about it
in sweet in the 17th century
we everybody saw them it's quite unquote
so there's no needy for that sort of
differentiation and all the needs of the
differentiation comes with aroused
colonialism the slave trade etc I'm not
a physical anthropologist but to the
best of my knowledge and understanding
we all have roots in Africa from Lucy
East Africa in general so I think the
colour makes a solid point to that
extent next call comes from Lawrence in
Granada Hills California hi Lawrence
hello dr. Horne I wanted to get your
take on the Reconstruction era and whom
I think is although it's debated around
in modern presidents but I think is the
worst president in the United States
history Andrew Johnson what is your take
on that well that's a title for which
there is significant competition I was
just reading I think it was in The
Washington Post today that someone was
telling James Buchanan the president
United States just before Abraham
Lincoln as the worst president in US
history because after all he helped it
was during his term that the Dred Scott
decision emerged of course he was not he
didn't write that decision but Andrew
Johnson of course in his attempts to
conciliate with the slave owning class
for example in his home state of
Tennessee if I'm not mistaken
helps to set back the freedom struggle
of the newly enslaved keep in mind as
well that one of the points is
oftentimes missing in this discussion of
civil war and reconstruction and I was a
u.s. history generally or the concerted
attempts to deport the black population
of the United States of America this was
not only the case or Abraham Lincoln who
even after the Emancipation Proclamation
was negotiating with the Brazilians with
regard to sending my ancestors through
Brazil as I say in my book
Hadean in the dr dominican republic
Ulysses as a grant was trying to send
the Negroes to Hispaniola and that
attempt barely failed if you look at
some contemporary work this new book of
strangers in their own land which is a
study of working-class conservatism and
middle-class conservatism in Louisiana
this sociologist who writes the book
takes away the point that many of these
white conservatives they see it black
Americans who work who excel or up to
including Barack Obama somehow are
jumping the queue in other words they
have this implicit idea of United States
as a white man's country as the
Democrats said in the election of 1864
and so our presence is somehow
illegitimate I was when I was at the
University of yes another David mr.
Georgia just a few weeks ago I was
reading in a congressional record from
1947 this idea even then of sending all
the Negroes back to Africa in the United
States so yes Andrew Johnson deserves a
program he deserves a critique searing
critique because of his failures and
reconstruction but if you look at them
in the broader context US history he
doesn't seem that unusual this is a text
from Steven Holl he tweets it at
historian speaks
why is conceptualizing African American
history and international terms
essential to understanding this
experience well first of all is Jesse
Jackson once said our presence in North
America is a result of a foreign policy
the African slave 3 when I teach
introduction African American Studies
one of the points I begin with is the
fundamental question which is how is it
that folks with roots in West Africa
minority in East Africa wind up in North
America speaking a language English
developed in northwest Europe obviously
this is a product of international
experience when I teach African American
history I'm sure
you could wake up my students who I'll
be teaching in Tuesday afternoon you
wake them up in the middle of the night
tonight and ask them the significance of
1453 they'll immediately spout well
that's the time when the Muslims were
able to seize what is now Istanbul
Constantinople which blocks the eastward
path to the riches of Asia Middle East
directly to the Spanish sending
Christopher Columbus across the ocean
blue in 1492 leading to the encounter
with the indigenous people we thought
were Indians which is one of the reasons
they're called Indians and then the
enslavement of Africans this is all part
of a global experience and so they try
to just limit it so the four corners of
North America and particularly in light
of what I've said about our alliances
with Spanish Florida our alliance with
the British against the settlers in the
war of 1812 alliances of Moscow
alliances with India alliances with
Japan the threat of limited custom North
America it seems to me is historical
malpractice let's hear from ed weeds in
Columbia Maryland hi ed weeds hello ed
dr. Horne a question that has never been
addressed and that is the aftermath of
the Haitian slave revolt
those who led the revolution through it
a French judge like this Eileen I'll be
pissed off they made themselves Emperor
and King and turned around and enslaved
their own that continued for four
hundred years right into Duvalier
who was really putting a lot of people
to death because they opposed him there
we could have used a good dose of
socialism Kosmos but the United States
government would not help Haiti because
they saw Duvalier as an ally against
communism so how long the poor Haitian
is going to continue to suffer the the
serious class system those
have a look this to look with disdain on
those who have not and there is no
progress being made if you have all the
money and employing people for just a
few cents a day there was also the rest
of it I don't know if you've heard of
them the little eight-year-old children
who have held and well who were left at
the doorstep of families so that they
could help clean the backyard in return
for a meal get no education I'm
desperate as to what can be done to
change a tea and make it better for the
people look I'm sorry I thought you're
finished that's a very difficult
question um like any revolutionary
process such as the Cuban revolutionary
process we were talking about it's very
difficult in these small countries to
embark upon this radical path as the
Haitians did at 1804 and have that path
be smooth she mentioned an estates and
the enmity from the United States after
the Haitian Revolution I talk in my book
about the fact that there is credible
evidence to suggest that then US
Secretary of State John C Calhoun the
hawkish South Carolinian by the way
continues to besmirch the Yale
University campus to this very day with
prominent buildings named after him
this leading not only slave older but
ideologist or slave owning that in one
of the most successful covert actions in
the long history of covert actions in
the state Johnson Calhoun played a
prominent role in helping to split the
island you notice that you have this one
smile island was shared by two nations
Haiti in the Dominican Republic this led
to incessant conflict between the two
nations that exist to this very day
perhaps the capstone of that process
being reached in the 1930s when dr
dominican republic dictator Rafael
Trujillo massacred thousands of Haitians
that kind of oppression and persecution
of Haitians along the border continues
to this very day then of course there's
the story that's often sole about how
they Haitians had to pay reparations to
the former slave owner not that the
French had to pay reparations to the
Africans they
slave but they Haitian government had to
pay preparation food through the French
and of course many of those rented then
migrated to Louisiana which helps to
shed light on why and the antebellum
period New Orleans probably had more
millionaires per capita than any of the
city in the United States of America so
the Haitian Road has been very difficult
then there was occupation by the United
States about a hundred years ago the
support of Duvalier the dictator and
then his son baby doc up to and
including and I hope my left-wing
friends don't get mad at me for saying
this the depredations of the Clinton
Foundation after the earthquake of
January 2010 and the credible
allegations of wrongdoing there oh so
the path for Haiti has been difficult
dead politically I've you know I've
written about India written about
African countries in the Caribbean
oftentimes I see my role is is focusing
on the u.s. role in these particular
countries and I've been criticized for
that perhaps understandably
unjustifiably but on the other hand I'm
very reluctant to from the comfort of
Washington DC so you issue these
stinging rebukes of these poor
developing countries that have had such
as a difficult path although I'm utterly
sympathetic to to what the caller's
talking about I had to visit Haiti to do
this research and it's not an easy
assignment living in Haiti nowadays
professor horn do you have any
right-wing friends my close friends
right-wing in terms of the black
community yes what does that mean that
means that I have many I have friends or
colleagues or associates who or
anti-white who think that this community
cannot be retained and once again I see
my role is to engage with special
to understand them oh but if I just
castigate and denounce them in light of
all what I've just been saying all this
evidence I'm not here to be very helpful
you're professor of history and
african-american studies at the
University of Houston why not just
American Studies well if they had
American Studies at the University of
Houston and coherent cognizable program
I'd probably be part of it um but I have
a sentimental and political attachment
to african-american studies this is the
field as recent historians have
suggested there was a product of
struggle these critiques that I've been
issuing of the historical profession in
terms of their omission of certain
subjects or their distortions of certain
subjects this was what called for this
is why black students when I was a
student we're demanding African American
Studies and I think that the need for it
continues to exist and I think that this
you should know that this Association
for the study of African American
license history which is meeting in
Richmond a few days it's reaching the
point where the membership of this
annual conventions are outstripping the
attendance at the annual conferences of
the associate organization for American
story ins and I think this is for a
number of reasons I think one people
like me the way I look at some of these
mainstream historical organizations is
that powerful eats that subject the
Negroes the Jim Crow they say yes sir
empower elites that ease up on Jim Crow
let the Negroes anything yes sir
now who knows what comes next whereas
this association I know as early as 1915
we could person like myself could go to
their meetings without feeling despised
so I think politically from my point of
view it's more important to support this
organization that's a matter of survival
and personal self-interest as much as
anything else the next call for Gerald
Horne comes from Lloyd in st. Louis hi
Lloyd
hello are you are you real good go ahead
sir yes when I asked dr. Horne is he
related to a George horn was like a
deputy fire chief he's retired now and
I'm a graduate of Sumner high school
over 65 years ago and a couple of topics
biracial
well many blacks or tri-racial for that
matter and then we talk about black
Republicans black was where Republicans
before white folks were Republicans at
least the southern white folks and now
then laughing has he read white trash by
Nancy Eisenberg I'll I'll hang up and
listen to your response again I'm proud
of you take care of wish you the very
best
bye now Lloyd before you leave Lloyd you
still with us yes
what did you do if you are retired what
did you do in st. Louis for living well
I'm a retired schoolteacher and also in
an attorney what are your politics
well I'm Democrat my parents were
Republicans when I was a kid I'm 82
years old and we had a mock election at
Sumner high school in the 50s and the
Republic Eisenhower won over Stevenson
so they're going to show you the history
of black folks in America thank you sir
George Sumner our George corn not to my
knowledge but as you know the these
naming practices in the black community
are very arbitrary I'm still not sure
how I got this heard his name that I now
carry a second of almost a second
question the second one was he went to
Sumner high school as schizos that was
at your high school now at the Beaumont
yeah then he talked about black
Republicans right oh yeah you know it's
true that Republican Party whose lineage
stretches back to the 1850s it starts
out being a party of the Negro so to
speak is Frederick Douglass ed the
Republican Party's to ship all Ellis's
to see of course the Negroes oftentimes
an alliance with
the business interests in the north of
course not necessarily an alliance with
working-class folk in the South were
Democrat with an armed wing called the
Ku Klux Klan and then that party system
begins to disintegrate with the New Deal
of the 1930s when black people begin to
desert the GOP and both of the Democrats
because of New Deal programs which by
the way oftentimes excluded them but
still they felt that that was choosing
the dirty shirt or the dirty t-shirt
this has been the oftentimes unsavory
choices that we've been faced with to
this point in 2016 well this was our
third session
have you read oh yeah maybe I should
provide news yes well I just made a call
that I write it or say it I can remember
but oh there's this literature coming
out of interest Rangers and their own
land
JD Vance's hillbilly elegy you probably
had him I'm sure on this program I mean
book TV um Nancy Heisenberg's white
trash and to a greater or lesser extent
it seems to me they're all trying to
explain this phenomenon that's staring
us in the face
watching post is a very interesting
article about this today this
working-class white woman in western
Pennsylvania who's supporting Trump
telazol house all these bizarre theories
about the Obama family some of which are
too delicate to mention how many TV um
and so nice the Eisenberg as a historian
is trying to trace this phenomenon how
poor whites have been treated over the
centuries I haven't read the book but
from the reviews I noticed some of the
reviews feel that there's also often
happens with those who examine this
phenomenon that they'd attended you know
there's this tendency amongst a story
it's always speak of agency the agency
of the oppressed slave revolts etc
people self assertion but when it comes
to white poor working-class people
voting Republican presumably against
their interests they're deprived of
agency they're all do
so which is it I mean do they have
agency or are they all dupes
I think the way to solve this conundrum
is to go back into history as I've been
suggesting over the past two hours or
more which is that at times it was
possible we'll pour your bins to get off
the boat and be part of this white
United Front good land taken from the
Native American stock with Africans and
soar up the class ladder and so perhaps
they think that history can repeat
itself and so perhaps they're not dupes
perhaps they're hey they're making a
cagey wager which is the phrase from my
1776 book that history can be reversed
my opinion is I hope they're wrong
somebody says to you I'm voting for
Donald Trump what's your gut reaction
what's your emotional react well it
depends on who that person is I mean if
it's Carl Icahn
he investor billionaire investor in New
York that's a I totally understand if
it's somebody a coal miner in West
Virginia or Eastern Kentucky I would do
what I'm suggesting that other people do
try to engage with them I mean try to
talk to them try to ask what do you
think you're going to get out of this uh
what do you think do you but at the same
time of course I think some of these
people who are voting for Donald Trump
will working-class I don't think that
the media here's a tip to the Washington
Post in New York Times they haven't used
the analogy sufficiently a Jesse Ventura
the professional wrestler who becomes
governor of Minnesota why did these
people in Minnesota think that a
professional wrestler no denigration
intended of wrestling I'm sure it's a
very noble and honorable profession the
fighter facing the Jesse Ventura would
make a good government I think that to a
certain degree there's a perverse sort
of anti elite sentiment operating that
they just want they want to bowl in the
china shop they just want somebody to
disrupt the status quo reminds me of
brexit in Britain with the number of
people voted for but I understand
because I mean obviously
the super state is a European Union like
Washington they tended to bail out the
wealthy and dump on the non wealthy but
at the same time Britain is going to
like these auto producing areas of
Britain where you have Japanese auto
plants they've already going to be
announced it going to be downsizing
investment so this is really going to
punish many of these Auto Workers who
voted for Brixton so once again I would
say that this is a direct product of
history that is to say not only was
we're left-wing trade unionists like
Harry bridges Ferdinand Smith purged
from the trade union movement which men
sitting on this right-leaning path which
helps to they stabilized the US working
class within the United States cuts this
deal with China for our decades ago
which is seen as a stroke of genius by
Richard Nixon but leads to massive
foreign direct investment of China which
obviously was not foreseen creating this
juggernaut that bits fair to be the
leading economy and country sooner
rather than later according to certain
economies a certain economist has
already occurred you might have noted
that in the first words out of Donald
Trump's mouth at the debate last Monday
was a denunciation of China and their
lies disaster because a conflict with
China I can't see any good coming out of
that kind of conflict and that's what
people apparently want to be voting for
do you think Donald Trump is a racist
well certainly I would say that his
actions be speak racism that is to say
the press has covered to a fairly well
this story about the housing project in
New York City where he was sued for
barring black potential black tenants I
would say that what helps to catapult
him to the front ranks of the Republican
Party in June 2015 when he descended the
escalator and Trump Tower to make his
announcement was this denunciation and
no uncertain terms of Mexicans and
people of Mexican origin that helped to
ignite anti-immigrant sentiment and as I
suggested in my 1776 book it's difficult
to maintain
white supremacy without a an
overwhelming white majority and
obviously that white majority is
shrinking which leads some to believe
that white supremacy in turn is
shrinking with those numbers and that
helps it seems to me to drive into his
ranks many whites who feel that they
have something to gain by reassertion or
reimagining a fortifying of white
supremacy so to that extent that reeks
of racism next call for Gerald Horne is
Allen Carthage North Carolina go ahead
out or presser orange I got an idea for
a book I'd love to talk more about a
white power I mean black power in
Appalachia the name of this book I've
been working on but I have an idea for
your book and that is to carry on from
your Dubois book a modern history of
n-double-a-cp say from when Julian Bond
of my brother from snick became
president up till today kind of through
the pin jealous period that last six
years and attempts my brother dr. barber
here in North Carolina Derrick Johnson
and Mississippi my brother in Texas and
other state movements in the old
Confederacy and how that has tried to of
bring the n-double-a-cp into the modern
era well that's a worthwhile project and
I would encourage anyone who embarks on
that project to pay careful attention to
how the n-double-a-cp has dealt with
foreign policy I mean for example the
scholar in Madison Wisconsin Brenda J
Plummer and her most recent book talks
about support in the highest ranks of
n-double-a-cp
for the war in Vietnam for example as
I've already noted there is
a certain kind of circumspection if you
like to use that euphemism of
n-double-a-cp leaders of the black
leaders about all these pressing crises
Syria Ukraine North Korea some of which
might be speak planetary extinction so I
think that the callers project is
worthwhile and I encouraged him to
pursue it this is a Facebook comment and
this is from Joanna Kane dr. horn do you
feel there is a connection between
African tribalism and Jim Crow here in
America and how this is the same system
playing a role in the numerous deaths in
Chicago which appears systemic this is a
hello from Joanna viewing at E so one
books oh that's the one books in Los
Angeles oh one they're having a
breakfast this morning to watch book TV
it's my favorite bookstore so I wish
that the joini would clarify it because
I'm not sure if I understand the import
of the question tribalism in Africa Jim
Crow tell you what Joanna @s Oh on why
don't you go ahead and make post another
comment
our producer here will keep an eye out
for it and let's see if we can get a
clarification on what you meant let's
hear from Bob in Huntsville Texas hi Bob
hi hi yeah go ahead I have a question
for the professor I was raised in Hawaii
and I lived in Hawaii back where Harry
bridges in fact I heard Harry bridges
talk one time I'm itching the man called
Davis I know Obama was a friend of his
he was an older man at that time but I
also know that Davis was born in Kansas
I haven't have been born in Kansas but
how how did this Davis get to Hawaii as
what did he do what he was there and how
did he meet Obama I know that he I have
heard that he was there to help Harry
bridges I don't know if that's true or
not well thank you I recommend Marshall
Davis a few moments ago when I talked
about some to context about why book and
health my remarks about him lost a
thousand right wing blogs with this
conspiracy theory about the relationship
between Frank Marshall Davis the black
radical
born in Kansas as the caller said comes
to maturity in Chicago and by the way
and like the next book I published is
called the rise and fall of the
Associated Negro Press by the University
of Illinois Preston Frank Marshall Davis
plays a prominent role there because he
was a journalist for this black version
of The Associated Press which had
journalists across the globe employed
most of the leading black writers of
that era including Richard Wright Zora
Neale Hurston at all Langston Hughes and
as The Associated Negro press started
turning to the right it couldn't
withstand the hammer blows of the Red
Scare even though before it was very
progressive evidenced by the fact that
at her Frank Marshall dirt Davis Davis
decided to move to why because that was
the the citadel of progressivism under
the US flag as I've already stated he
did know Harry bridges he did work a bit
with the ILWU but that wasn't his
primary gig or his primary job I must
say although you can check my book on
fighting and paradise by the universal I
trust to double check that now
apparently Frank Marshall Davis knew
Barack Obama's paternal grandparents
particularly the father mr. Dunham and
it was apparently through mr. Dunham
that the young Barack Obama met Frank
Marshall Davis of course the young brock
obama comes back from indonesia to stay
with his grandparents in honolulu and go
to school there that's how he encounters
Frank Marshall Davis this is Greg Carr
tweeting in professor Horne how do you
interpret the use by some scholars of
the phrase quote our history as an
African American history it's American
history I understand the sentiment that
came up in a sort of a strange way
during Barack Obama's remarks at the
opening of the African American History
Museum we said something that I can't
remember the quote but with something
like
you know this museum helps to show the
black america is not a burden
it was something like that which i found
to be sort of off-putting and i think
that because of the very strong white
supremacy that still describes the land
that and because of what I've already
made reference to which these persistent
and consistent efforts deport the black
people from North America that black
scholars feel that they always have to
assert that they're part of this project
they're part of this narrative so I
actually had a sort of a defensive
reaction that's how I interpreted at
least although I dare say there will
come a time when that kind of
defensiveness won't be necessary but if
I'm sure of that
Cornel West writing in a critique of
Tallahassee Coates book between the
world and me quote how I wish the
prophetic work of serious intellectuals
like Robin DG Kelly Imani Perry Gerald
Horne Eddie Glaude commanded the
attention the corporate media gives
codes well um
you try to put me on the hot seat here I
admire Cornel West I think he's one of
the towering intellectuals of this era
I'm happy to call him a friend
I don't know Tana ha seacoast but I'm
Meyers what I read between the world of
me I think he's a very good writer I
understand why the book is been a
runaway bestseller because it's short
well-written and easily digestible I
think it's anti-racist in fact you might
be interested to know that there are
certain left-wing writers who criticize
Coates for being anti-racist lately they
questioned their whole concept believe
it or not I won't go down the rabbit
hole on that concept but this is it
shows you the ideological confusion we
find ourselves so I guess the bottom
line is that despite my utter admiration
for Cornel West I don't necessarily
share his critique of mr. Coates gales
calling in for
Bethesda Maryland here in the suburbs of
Washington hi Gail hi how are you good
dr. Horne thank you for your time I'll
make my questions fast do you think
Hollywood in the north are just as
responsible for the continuation of
racism racism in this country and I'll
explain why I asked with four quick
points
sure it's after the war the North let
the South have its way - we have
Confederate monuments not only yourself
but throughout this entire nation three
juxtaposed to Germany there are no
monuments or movies extolling National
Associates leaders and the flag is
villain lied tour it wasn't just gone
with the wind the Confederacy narrative
was skillfully interwoven and many old
Hollywood movies recently asked for a
1954 movie titled about miss Leslie the
Confederacy had nothing to do with the
closet's movie but the statement he made
in the movie Robert Lee you can't
question his character and I find this
disturbing and I feed in a lot of
Hollywood movies all right that scale in
Bethesda well you're gonna have to
remind me of some of these points but
yes the interesting thing about the
African slavery was that it was largely
financed from the north places like New
York City Newport Rhode Island which was
an early citadel in the late 17th
century of the African slave trade and
then the Africans were brought to the
Caribbean and to Dixie and as when I was
my book on the African slave trade to
Brazil the role of US Nationals New York
was a centerpiece of financing of the
African slave trade to Brazil as a
matter of fact the late great historians
Philip s phoner one of his first books
was on the role of New York in terms of
African slavery and by the way I was
just showing some of my students in
class at Houston just a few days ago
eclipsed from the film Gangs of New York
which depicts the anti-negro riots there
circa 1860 to the US of A War when these
are people fresh off the boat feels that
they're being conscripted to go free the
Negroes and of course they ride start
hanging people from street lamps that's
subtle
so yes both
New York in particular carries a heavy
burden with regard to slavery and racism
just offloading this all into Dixie just
won't wash and by the way I mean my
friends in New York I mean some of them
are living in a cocoon I mean you would
think New York was red Vienna where
actually when Eric garner the black
American who was strangled on camera in
the process of selling loose cigarettes
in 2014 on Staten Island New York by New
York City police officers the prosecutor
who failed to bring an indictment Daniel
Donovan when they was promoted he was
elected to Congress and this
cosmopolitan also obeying New York so
the caller has a very solid point and
similarly for Hollywood one of the
reasons I've written it less about
Hollywood is because it's complicity in
terms of these damaging stereotypes it
did not begin nor in we've gone with
wind
of course Birth of a Nation coming out
of circa a century ago DW Griffith
glorifies the Ku Klux Klan which makes
it rather ironic and perhaps pleasing
that a new birth of a nation is being
released in a few days about the net
turn of slave revolt which I can't wait
to see and one more point on in New York
I serve on the board of this publication
that's left of liberal and said quarters
of New York and what's interesting is
that my 1776 book visit except to unpack
the creation myth the United States it's
been wrapped just rapidly the seed black
Americans because I think it's not so
much because the thesis I've showed I'm
fighting like America is like to be seen
fighting against slavery even though
some of these new school of historians
to talk about capitalism slavery they
don't show that as a matter of fact and
one passage from this one book of the
capitalism is slavery school it's very
close the scholar is telling this black
student I'm sorry I couldn't find
episodes of resistance and revolt
against let me read about the Seminole
Wars 1819 to 1855 in Florida the Creole
slaver vote 1941 the Negroes are vote
and take the boat to Bahamas and then
are freed by the British Army they're
also
episodes but anyway this this left of
liberal journal written and reviewing my
book they said I was hacking fight I've
been sitting next to these squares for
years
hidden these meetings and accused of
being in the tank for Britain when I
praised British British abolitionism
accused even on this illustrious program
for being into the tanks of Moscow what
they fight I mean I mean I know that if
you critique the creation myths of
Israel you can be accused of being
anti-semitic can't accuse I don't know
if you create the you critique the
creation myth the United States of
America you can be accused of being anti
white but that's where we are right now
in terms of ideological confusion that
I've already made reference to what is
that publication they don't deserve a
mention on this illustrious program
class struggle in Hollywood is the name
of the book and you write so much has
been made of the alleged red influence
on the movies content anti red
propaganda is easier to discern well for
sure that's the understatement of the
decade I mean how was the Communists for
the FBI for example I mean there's a
although as I also talked about in this
book which is worth repeating that
during World War two when the United
States and the Soviet Union were in
alliance at the behest of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt Hollywood started
producing these prose Moscow movies like
mission of Moscow but you might be able
to find on YouTube which presents Joseph
Stalin as benevolent leader much loved
by his people a song of Russia over all
these Pro Soviet movies produced during
World War two and interestingly enough
even though black people such as Dubois
have been criticized for their alleged
pro-moscow sympathies that were
supposedly not in sync with black
aspirations the United States itself can
be accused of pull mark pro-moscow
sympathies to save its skin during World
War two I guess there's one standard for
the u.s. willing to lead it's another
standard for oppressed black people but
despite the example one beta is Reds
which is a very interesting movie which
we're going to be marking the 100th
anniversary of the Bolshevik Revolution
next year and on that movie should be
brought other than out of them the
closets of the speak because it's very
interesting and very illuminating about
the Bolshevik Revolution but what's what
has me interested in Hollywood even more
today is what you'll find I think it's
in the New York Times today certainly
its minute LA Times about the longer
group out of China which isn't buying up
all the movie theaters in the United
States it has an investment deal with
Sony with the course as a Japanese
corporation I think it bought a watched
about one of the big six studios and
Congress right there in this city is
getting very concerned about the Banda
Group and its investments in Hollywood
and of course supposedly the wonder
group or some Chinese concern perhaps is
interested in showing your movies in
China cause the new movie Red Dawn which
is a remake of the old anti-soviet movie
from the 1980s the shoes Soviet invasion
I think it's of a Colorado they wanted
to have it at first to be the Chinese
invasion of North America but apparently
they were concerned about the Chinese
market concerned about the Wanda group
Chinese interests in Hollywood so it's
changed to the North Korean state they
also this country of nineteen million
people is gonna invade the United States
this behemoth of 330 million people no
wonder its ranked at the box-office 4630
strikes in America you write in 1945 and
1946 well there's a lot of pent-up
energy of course there's the so-called
no strike pledge of World War two with
this idea that because of the United
States and this death match with Berlin
Tokyo and Rome that it requires the
ultimate sacrifice by at least by the
working class but then there's this
pent-up energy after World War two not
only because in the most right place but
I would also say because of the
progressivism unleashed by the
anti-fascist war by the communists or
elected office Ben Davis who wrote a
biography about what I mentioned a few
moments ago elected New York City
Council on
so the CIO is surging the Congress of
Industrial Organizations which is now
merged with the American Federation of
Labor to form the afl-cio then merger
takes place in 1955 so that leads to
this great labor upsurge including in
Hollywood which is the subject of my
book class struggle in Hollywood
of course the Union the conference of
studio unions is red baited and its
leaders or charged with being communist
although I show that they weren't but
this was a too convenient a charge to
miss out on and so the Union was
bludgeoned into submission
although I do point out and my other
book on Hollywood on the biography of
John Howard lost in the Jewish American
who's the founder of the swing writer
skill and wrote some of the most
powerful anti races cinema scenes in the
history of Hollywood including under the
so called blacklist
Cry the Beloved Country the first
version based on the South African novel
I put forth the thesis in that book that
the screenwriters in some ways were the
most sophisticated politically and I
argue that one of the reasons why we
speak of film as being a Steven
Spielberg movie even though he just
directed and that did not necessarily
write the screenplay and parted to blow
into screenwriters who were dominated at
least their guilt their union was not
only about people like John Howard
Lawson Dalton Trumbo who of course is a
comrade as well who is just the subject
of a Hollywood movie just briefly so
it's not bad as interesting um I'd
really like the tackle Hollywood again
because they have so many stories worth
telling what does a what does the
American Communist Party stand for today
well I would say it stands for socialism
I would say that it stands for workers
right so it's a stands for anti racism
I would say that it stands for non
interventionist foreign policy ah but I
would say like many communist parties
around the world it's
tremendously in the wake of the collapse
of the socialist project in Eastern
Europe which is another story because
even though you had people cheerleading
for the collapse of the socialist camp
in Eastern Europe if you look at what's
replaced it
many people who are cheerleading for
these replacements are unhappy as a
matter of fact what's interesting once
your grandchildren begin to look at the
US foreign policy I think that they'll
be struck by the fact that there was
hostility to Moscow during the Cold War
and there might be even more hostility
today even though the Communists are not
in power and I think your grandchildren
are asked well I thought getting out the
Communists would improve things
apparently it hasn't so unless there
must be something else going on here
that's that's the way a historian should
think and then the question is what else
is going on that leads to this continuum
of antagonism or for example if you look
at Hungary with the or bond regime which
is as overtones of anti-semitism
anti-immigrant chaos that's being sold
people were cheerleading for whether
they knew it or not for people like or
bond to take over from the communist and
now you have this but there hasn't been
a return to look at that question to
figure out what happened I mean I think
it's a line from the Great Gatsby about
how these folks you know they create all
this damage and then they just walk away
oh this is what's been happening Shaw de
San Francisco please go ahead with your
question or comment for Gerald Horne on
book TV thank you so much for this
opportunity to engage with dr. Horne I
am in awe of your scholarship and and
what I really wanted to do is pick
piggyback on the caller from Bethesda
who spoke on the monuments that had been
developed thus far in this country but I
really wanted you to reflect on the need
of more monuments and historical sites
to people who chopped and picked and
planted cotton and to speak on the
African connection to that and its
overall contribution to the American
economy but more specifically to the
Confederates and how Jefferson Davis in
fact who owned Davis Bend one of the
major cotton plantations in America and
which in fact fueled his Confederacy
movement but Benjamin Montgomery if you
have any reference to him and his
contributions to you know the ownership
of Davis Ben how in fact he didn't fact
become an owner of Jefferson Davis's
plantation and him being the forerunner
of mound Bayou Mississippi and the first
one of the first black townships but
more specifically really what I wanted
to talk about is the need to have a
monument in tribute to that cotton
narrative and the white in fact is one
of our team members and we are currently
working on this project who is away from
anything who haven't occurred we is
conferring Inc out of Mississippi Delta
Indianola Mississippi and Mississippi
Valley State University but we are a
team of people BB King was our honorary
chair along with dr. Maya Angelou
currently we have dr. Bobby Rush who is
the honorary chair but I would love to
have professor corn scholarship our
opinion about the need to have a
monument that is that our historic site
that speaks to the significance of
cotton and the American South or the
American content are they calling in
from San Francisco well first of all I
say right on to the idea of monuments to
those who pick the cotton as I'm sure
the caller knows more than most slavery
was not a sideshow in terms of the
antebellum US economy slavery was the
main event
that's where capital was flowing as a
matter of fact one of the theses I'm
going to develop that this association
of meeting in Richmond I keep making
reference to is the idea that we may
even need a redefinition of the term
imperialism to take into account slavery
in the sense of seeing the export of
capital is not only being banking
capital
being exported from New York to the
Americas but seeing capital and human
bodies being exported from the African
continent to Brazil to Cuba to North
America as this kind of precursor of
imperialism and then trying to see arise
and think that through with regard to
cotton in particular is a new book by
this Harvard professor whose name
escapes me right now which you might
want to look at I'm sure you just put
those names those phrases into a search
engine the book will pop up which will
have new insight I'm sure and to cotton
in terms of my southern African research
one of the points that I have now come
to is that if from mile my own research
is that if you look at the cotton
industry
um what's impart happening is that after
the u.s. Civil War you see the rise of a
slave trade in Melanesia to Queensland
Australia and to Fiji with bonded labor
Melanesians of course look just like me
let's talk about in my University of why
you press book the white Pacific and
this of course leads directly for now
exclude some of the intervening steps to
the overthrow that Y and Kingdom in the
1890s and the incorporation of politie
why is the state and then as the state
in 1959 and if you disregard the priests
September 19 2016 Donald J Trump they
elect the birth of Barack Obama in
August 1961 but I'm also coming to the
conclusion that you had a sort of
exporting of the cotton industry to
Africa which is interesting back to
Africa with cotton workers or enslaved
laborers being thrown out of work if you
like or not being no longer being slaves
and then that industry taking root in
Africa like in places like Uganda for
example and that's I'm going to be
developing that from my southern Africa
book now with regards to Jefferson Davis
of course the Jefferson Davis papers
they're receiving some multi-volume set
you can find it at any decent college
library and if you look at the Jefferson
Davis papers in the
index you'll be able to find I'm sure
references that Davis been super
Montgomery to mount by you and the other
points that you just raised and I would
also make this point the historian
Judith Carney in her book on rice has
pointed out that if you look at the the
rice industry in South Carolina that the
slave traders oftentimes we're not just
willy-nilly picking up Africans they
were looking for Africans with certain
skills as I've told my students it's
like a you know it's slave traders come
to United States they say ok we might
want to mathematician so in craft
mathematics so they were great grabbing
people who are growing rice in West
Africa and then bringing them to
Carolina which helps to which it leads
to the rice industry flourishing in
inker Alana that CA rney
he wants to follow Tiwari
you have 15 seconds to make your point
Greenville Mississippi I have two brief
questions my first question is in
regards to african-american history is
there any book in particular that you
would recommend that like puts it all in
the next year ok my second and the
second question is in regards to police
brutality's I'm originally from
Milwaukee Wisconsin and I'm seeing a
vist transpire lives and by the time
they get to the news is manipulated and
distorted is there anything possible is
there anything that you would suggest
that we could possibly do thank you -
very and unfortunately you have 15
seconds to answer the question ok I
missed the second part but I would save
it Erika Duffy of the University of
Illinois and Leslie Alexander of Ohio
State preparing a new textbook on
african-american history I think that
they'll include incorporate these newer
revelations it's not out yet but I
expected to be out soon and so the
caller should be looking for if people
want to get a hold of you via social
media what's the best place for them to
do so well they should put my name into
a search engine my email address will
come up if you want to hear me talk put
my name into the youtube search engine
the soundcloud search engine the twitter
search engine and you'll get more
our guest for the last three hours here
on book TV has been University of
Houston historian and author Gerald
Horne we appreciate your time today on
both TV thank you